the
9,4 21st meeting of the Security Council
is called to
order the provisional agenda for this
meeting is maintenance of International
Peace and
security upholding the purposes and
principles of the United Nations Charter
through effective
multilateralism maintenance of peace and
security of
Ukraine the agenda is
adopted I would like to warmly welcome
the Secretary General distinguished
presidents Prime Ministers ministers and
other high level Representatives present
in the security Council chamber your
presence today underscores the
importance of the subject matter under
discussion in accordance with with rule
37 of the council's provisional rules of
procedure I invite representatives of
Argentina Australia Austria Belarus
Belgium Bosnia and
Herzegovina Bulgaria Canada Chile
Croatia czechia Denmark Estonia Germany
Greece Guatemala Hungary India Indonesia
Ireland Italy Kuwait lvia
lonstein Lithuania Mexico
Montenegro the kingdom of the
Netherlands North Macedonia Panama
Poland Portugal Qatar the Republic of
Korea Romania Sierra Leon Slovakia
Slovenia South Africa Spain turkey
Ukraine and the bolivarian Republic of
Venezuela to participate in the
meeting in accordance with rule 39 of
the council's provisional rules of
procedure I also invite the following
briefers to participate in this meeting
his Excellency Mr charl Michelle
president of the European Council his
Excellency Mr buar Osmani chairperson in
office of the organization for security
and cooperation in Europe and his
Excellency Grand Chancellor Ricardo pno
de monteo Sovereign Order of Malta it is
so
decided I also propose that the council
invite his Excellency Archbishop Paul
Richard Gallagher secretary for
relations with States and international
organizations of the Holy sea to
participate in the meeting
in accordance with the provisional rules
of procedure and the previous practice
in this
regard there being no objection it is so
decided the delegation of Russian
Federation has asked for the floor
please you have the
floor
Mr
President you were Hasty in saying the
words it is so decided we had two
questions first and foremost we wish to
ask you on what basis you propose to
give the president of Ukraine Vladimir
zilinski the floor before members of the
security Council speak many of whom also
are represented at the level of heads of
state and government and my second
question the second question I wish to
pose is on what basis are you inviting
the minister for foreign affairs of
North
Macedonia to today's meeting in the
capacity as the chair of the
occe so I take note of uh the
remarks made by the Russian
delegation and uh in response I would
like to
confirm that notice of the speaking
order was given to all council members
in
advance and in my view it would have
been preferable had this procedure
procedural matter been resolved at a
technical level prior to the start of
this open debate so that we would have
been able to proceed immediately to the
substance of our deliberation
today I wish to recall that paragraph
33 of presidential Note S
5007 agreed by consensus States and I
quote when non-members are invited to
speak to the security Council those who
have a direct interest in the outcome of
the matter under consideration may speak
prior to council members if appropriate
end of quote given the subject of
today's open debate we believe that
inviting president zalinski to speak
before council
members amply confirms to paragraph
33 more however giving the floor first
to president zalinski will provide the
opportunity for council members and the
other member states participating today
in such impressive numbers to respond to
his remarks previously in February of
this year the Russian delegation raised
the same issue and was assured by then
the council president that umle
precedents exist of non-council member
states taking the floor before council
members several cases were cited at that
time and others could be mentioned I
would add that at each of the previous
five Security Council meetings in which
president zalen
was invited to participate he spoke
before council members I want to assure
our Russian colleagues and everyone here
that this is not a special operation by
the Albanian
presidency but a continuation of a long
and wellestablished practice of this
Council and today's speaking order
therefore is in full
Conformity with the council's guidelines
and practices as for the second question
question
I have a certain difficulty to
understand what's the
problem because uh oce has an important
role and uh is uh here because of its
contribution to this meeting considered
of
essence yes the O representative here is
in
Albanian from North
Macedonia
but if you would be more explicit what
the problem I would be happy
to help
you with pleasure Mr
President we do not believe that the
arguments that you have advanced are
compelling there are a number of members
of the of of the security Council that
will be represent presented in the hall
today at the head of state level you try
to explain why the Ukrainian president
is being prioritized however the
procedure this is nothing to do with the
procedure for the security Council you
can understand the logic when we
discussed Somalia here the president of
Somalia spoke first here but he was the
only president from among those present
uh there are indeed presidents related
to other files on the security council's
agenda but and uh a specific practice
has unfolded linked to the specificity
specificities of certain regions which
has nothing to do with the situation in
Ukraine I would like to warn you that if
today you bang the gabble gavel there by
implementing your decision the Albanian
presidency will be tainted with an
egregious precedent of violating
existing practice in the security
Council established practice for the
benefit of one delegation which time of
a Time continues to demonstrate with
support from the West that their rules
don't apply to it and everything is
permissible from the beginning Western
members of the security Council three
times pushed through the participation
of Vladimir zilinsky in Security Council
meetings uh through video link this
constitutes a BL blatant disregard for
the authority of this key body lead
other states find time in their schedule
to personally to travel in person to New
York and to speak before the members of
council over the course of the 75 years
of the existence of the organization the
Emergen uh Presence at the security
Council speaking before the council was
viewed to be a privilege the same
applies to statements from the lofty
Tribune of the general assembly instead
of which during the last session during
the special session the representative
of Kev decided to speak through video
link at the same time Western
delegations alleged that last year
Vladimir zilinski was unable to leave
the country due to extraordinary
circumstances these circumstances
nonetheless did not prevent him from
traveling to the US to visit Washington
and yet he did not Dain at the time to
travel personally to the United Nations
colleagues consider uh the violation of
the president by the president of the
practice of the work of the Security
Council is fraught with risks of
undermining the authority of the
security Council which they are trying
to transform into a oneman standup show
and for this the Albanian presidency
convened an open debate uh in this
debate a large group of supporters from
among NATO countries and it's is clear
for many at least for most that today's
meeting is nothing more will be nothing
more than a spectacle I would like to
stress for protocol and for those who
are trying to distort our position we do
not object to the participation of the
Ukrainian president in this meeting but
this needs to be done in line with the
rules of procedure and existing practice
According to which countries invited
under rule 37 speak after the members of
the security Council especially when as
both members of the council and a number
of other Representatives under rule 37
are represented at the head of state and
government level turning to the
participation of the Albanian foreign
minister and of North Macedonia
apologize as the speaker as a current
chair chairperson in office of the oce
uh our being appalled at this has
nothing to do with his nationality sir
and we objected to his presence in this
capacity and we informed the Albanian
presidency about this
yesterday we failed to understand as far
as we understand there's been no
discussion of this or any open
discussion of at the building where or
or in in Vienna the headquarters there
was no discussion according to approved
principles by the permanent Council of
the oce any statements of chairperson in
Office the Secretary General of the oce
or official Representatives authorized
by them need to be in line with their
mandates and they must not depart from
the consensual position of the OC if the
Albanian chair presidency insists on
allowing Mr asmani to speak during
today's meeting we believe that he can
voice only the consensual position of
this organization I would note uh
separately that the OC
uh due to the destructive approach
adopted by Western delegations has long
not been in any way contributing to the
process of resolving the Ukrainian
crisis but it has only been exacerbating
the situation we see this in attempts to
advance and push
through in a way that runs counter to
practice Mr osman's uh Mr osman's
participation uh by Western delegations
their attempt to advance one-sided rules
of the game as part of the rules based
order we urge members of Security
Council to adopt a principal position in
this issue and to speak out against such
approaches we regret that that Albanian
presidency has demonstrated blatant
disregard for consensual and practices
of Security Council they have placed
their NATO uh political and ideological
beliefs above the obligations of the
presiden of SEC Council which is a
guardian for the procedures and should
adopt an impartial position
unfortunately the uh Albania has been
unable to manage this today thank
you I must say that uh coming from you
all this lecture of violating uh the
rules in this building is quite an
impressive uh shoot but uh as far as you
repeat
it uh many
times that uh the violation here is
about President zalinski speaking
uh before the me council
members there is a soltion for this if
you agree you stop the war and president
zalinsky will not take the
floor so what made him here important
and what makes important for all of us
to hear him first and then discuss is
made from you not from us thank you very
much I take take notes and we'll
continue with
our with our
session you want the floor again
okay Mr President I wish to draw your
attention to the fact that you today are
are acting as president of the security
Council not speaking in your National
capacity as a representative of Albania
your objective is to conduct a meeting
as is enshrined in the rules of
procedure of the security Council
instead of providing political
assessments in Your Capacity as the
president of the security Council thank
you I just responded to you after you
addressing me as the Albanian prime
minister and after you continuing to say
incorrect things about what the
procedure is here if you don't want me
to answer as an Albanian prime minister
don't provoke me as such
anyhow let uh keep going now the
security again
okay Mr President I Turn to You only as
the president of the security Council
not once did I turn to you as the prime
minister of Albania once again I stress
I'm engaged in a procedural dialogue
with you not in a substantive dialogue
please refrain from a political
assessments at the beginning of your
statement at the council
yeah it was you that talked about NATO
about Albania being in NATO about NATO
count is coming here so all this has
nothing to do with my role as president
of the council anyhow can we now with
your permission continue normally the
session thank you very much the security
Council now begin its consideration of
item two of uh
agenda I wish to draw the attention of
council members first to document s
60653 a letter dated 6 September 2023
from the permanent representative of
Albania to the United Nations addressed
to the president of the security
Council I now give the floor to the
Secretary General his Excellency Mr
Antonio
Gutierrez Mr President
excellencies the United Nations Charter
is our road map to a more peaceful
world the tools and mechanisms founded
on the principles of the charter are
how-to manual to resolve
conflict together our Collective efforts
over the years have contributed to
preventing war on a global scale and
saving millions of lives through
peacemaking and preventing
diplomacy un peacekeeping
operations disarmament and
non-proliferation effort efforts
humanitarian and development programs
and activities to promote human
rights
set just this
week the sustainable development goals
Summit agreed a rescue plan for the
SGS an essential tool to prevent
conflicts and crises of all
kinds multilateralism works it is
essential and
effective but multilateral tools and
mechanisms are weaking in the face of
rising geopolitical tensions and
challenges some are failing While
others Frameworks that are urgently
needed do not yet
exist the number of conflict related
deaths last year almost
doubled Un Peace operations are under
unprecedented
strain nuclear disarmament is at a
virtual standstill and there are no
adequate Global Frameworks to address
the security threats posed by new
technologies I urge governments to go
further and do better to recommit to
their obligations under the UN
Charter to use the full range of
diplomatic tools that it
provides to prioritize the preven ion of
conflict and crisis and to consider the
proposals for new Frameworks and tools
in the new agenda for
peace Mr
President Russia's invasion of Ukraine
in clear violation of the United Nations
chter and international law is
aggravating geopolitical tensions and
divisions threatening Regional
stability increasing the nuclear threat
and creating deep fissures in our
increasingly multi-polar
worlds all this comes at a time when
cooperation and compromise for
multilateral Solutions are needed more
than ever to tackle challenges from the
climate crisis to unprecedented levels
of inequality to disrup disrupted
Technologies the United Nations organs
have been clear in condemning the
war the general assembly overwhelmingly
approved to a resolution demanding that
Russia leave Ukraine and the second
rejecting Russian's effort to Annex
Ukrainian
territory I have consistently and
repeatedly call for a just and
sustainable peace in Ukraine in line
with the charter and international law
for Ukraine for Russia and for the
world Russia's invasion was followed by
Relentless systematic attacks against
civilians and civilian infrastructure
and services including health and
education
facilities the war has killed or injured
tens of thousands of civilians destroyed
lives and Lively Woods traumatized a
generation of children torn families and
communities apart devastated the economy
and turned vast areas of Farmland into
deadly Mine
Fields attacks on civilians and civilian
infrastructure must stop
immediately nearly half of Ukraine's
population some 18 million people need
humanitarian assistance and protection
more than 6 million ukrainians have fled
the
country the United Nations has worked
collectively to mitigate the impact on
people both in Ukraine and around the
world and to support
civilians our humanitarian programs have
stepped up Distributing Aid to more than
8 million people this year in
partnership with over 450 humanitarian
organizations all of them
Ukrainian the international atomic
energy agency has EST Lish a presence at
zapia nuclear plant and other major
Ukrainian nuclear sites to monitor
safety security and safe
guards together with the international
Committee of the Red Cross we
successfully organized the evacuation of
civilians from the azof stal still plant
in marup Paul last
year evidence of shocking and widespread
human rights violations has been
documented by un agencies including conf
with related sexual violence arbitrary
detentions summary
executions mostly by the Russian
Federation and the forcible transfer of
Ukrainian civilians including children
to territory under Russian control or to
the Russian
Federation this documentation is vital
for
accountability and accountability for
all human rights violation is crucial in
line with International norms and
standards Mr President the war
contributed to an unprecedented surge in
global food prices threatening Millions
with hunger and
poverty starting in July
2022 we succeeded in mitigating that
impact through the Black Sea initiative
and the memorandum of understanding
between the UN and the Russian
Federation during its one-ear period of
operation the Black Sea initiative
together with memoranda of understanding
on facilitating exports of Russian food
products and fertilizers have helped to
reduce Global food prices by over
23% from the record I reached in March
last year the Black Sea initiative
enabled the export of 33 million metric
tons of grain and food stuffs and
allowed world food program to transport
725,000 metric tons of wheat for
humanitarian Aid to countries including
Afghanistan and
Somalia under the memoranda of
understanding the United Nations
delivered Solutions on several of the
most challenging ing areas of trade
facilitation for Russian food and
fertilizers with continues work on the
remaining
issues we deeply regret that Russia
ended its participation in the Black Sea
initiative in July of this year and that
immediately upon leaving Russia launched
a bombardment of Ukrainian ports and
grain storages facilities on the Black
Sea and the danub
river attacks against Terminals and
grain stores are unacceptable and such a
s must
end civilian shipping in the Black Sea
has also been threatened further
escalation could instantly shock the
stock shock the markets and destabilize
the
region volatility and uncertainty have
already return to International grain
markets while supplies from the Harvest
in Ukraine pile
up the bombardment is also undermining
our efforts in the implementation of the
memorandum of understanding with the
Russian Federation
it is Le it has led many of those whose
Goodwill is needed notably in the
private sector to question whether there
is any real interest in returning to the
Black Sea
initiative we remain engaged with all
parties aiming to ensure safe and secure
exports of grain and fertilizer from
Russia and Ukraine and these must be put
on a stable footing without the repeated
threat of
interruption I'm grateful to the
government of turkey for its
contribution
and urge all member states to support
our
efforts Mr President the United Nations
continues to work towards the just and
Lasting peace in Ukraine in line with
the charter international law and
resolutions of the general assembly I
urge all countries to do their part to
prevent further escalation and to lay
the foundations for sustainable
peace we are fully committed to the
sovereignity independence and
territorial Integrity of Ukraine within
its intern nationally recognized
borders this war is already causing
Limitless suffering its continuation
risks further perilous
escalation there is never an alternative
to dialogue diplomacy and a just peace
thank
you I thank the Secretary General for
this briefing and I now give the floor
to his Excellency Mr volodimir zalinski
President of
Ukraine
thank you
so thank
you distinguished prime minister RMA I'm
grateful to the Albanian presidency for
the organization of this meeting Mr
Secretary General ladies and
gentlemen since the start of the
fullscale aggression launched by the
state which for some reason is still
present here and on the permanent name
members of the UN Security Council
there's already been 574 days of pain
losses and struggle Russia has killed at
least tens of thousands of our people
and turned Millions into refugees by
destroying their homes most of the world
recognizes the truth about this war it
is a criminal and unprovoked aggression
by Russia against our nation aimed at
seizing Ukraine's territory and
resources but it's not just that the
terrorist state is
willing through its aggression to
undermine all the grounds of
international Norms meant to protect the
world from the wars and I'm grateful to
all those who have recognized Russian
aggression as the violation of the UN
Charter Ukraine exercises its right to
selfdefense helping Ukraine with weapons
um in this exercise by imposing
sanctions and exerting comprehensive
pressure on the aggressor as well as
voting for Relevant resolution would
mean helping to defend the UN Charter
the resolutions of the general assembly
have clearly recognized the fact that
the only source of this war is Russia
but this has changed nothing for Russia
in the United Nations however these are
the situations that have changed
everything for the UN we should
recognize that the UN find itself in a
deadlock on the matters of aggression
humankind no longer opines its hopes on
the UN when it comes to the defense of
the Sovereign borders of Nations world
leaders are seeking new platforms and
alliances that could reduce the
disastrous scope of problems the
problems that are met here within this
walls with rhetoric rather than real
solutions with aspirations to compromise
with Killers rather than to protect
lives life should be defended
uncompromisingly to ensure successful
protection but I would not be here today
if Ukraine had no proposals precisely
regarding some specific Solutions
yesterday in my address to the UN
General Assembly I said that Ukrainian
peace formula had become the basis to
update the existing security
architecture in the world to restore the
real power of the UN Charter and the
rule based International order
now I would like to present some very
specific details based on the peace
formula notably it's
.5 and it's called implementation of the
UN Charter and the restoration of
Ukraine's territorial integrity and the
world order all in the world can see
what makes the UN incapable
unfortunately this seat in the security
Council which Russia occupies illegally
through backstage manipulations
following the collapse of the Soviet
Union have been taken by Liars whose job
is to whitewash the aggression and the
genocide being carried out by Russia and
all the UN actions either by the
security Council or by the general
assembly that could have sto this
aggression or Shattered by the privilege
granted to the aggressor with this seat
veto power in the hands of the aggressor
is what has pushed the UN into a
deadlock today no matter what nation you
might be a nation with hundreds of
millions of people or a small nation a
nation that bravely defends its
independence or a country whose long
history of Independence can help others
a state in need of help or a nation that
could provide some genuine support a
state relying on its army or a state
considering the UN
Charter but not the Army as its first
and last line of defense regardless of
who you are the current un system still
makes you
less influential than the veto power
possessed by a few and misused by one
Russia that is to the detriment of all
other UN members these days in the
general assembly we can hear the world
inequality too often inequality is
mentioned by different nations both
larger and smaller it is preciser
inequality that renders the UN
ineffective I regret that so far the UN
Security Council is just the largest and
the most visible platform in the world I
believe and I know that un is capable of
more I'm confident that the UN cha can
actually work for the sake of peace and
security globally however for this to
happen the yearslong discussions and
projects on un reform must be trans
translated into a viable process of un
reform and it should not be only about
representation here in the security
Council the use of veto power that is
what requires the reform and this could
be a key reform that is something that
can restore the power of the UN Charter
ladies and
gentlemen 574 days of the full-fledged
Russian aggression means 574 reasons for
changes in this chamber and the numbers
of votes in favor of this challenges
actually amounts to billions the
absolute majority of people in the world
want to leave in the world free of
aggression in contrast of all us there's
only a few obsessed individuals Moscow
vetto right should not serve those who
are obsessed with hatred and War what we
observe in the United Nations in
increasing support for their idea that
in cases of mass
atrocities against human
rights veto power should be voluntarily
suspended but we can also observe that
Russia will not give up this stolen
privilege
voluntarily therefore the UN General
Assembly should be given a real power to
overcome the veto this will be the first
necessary step if it is impossible to
stop the war because all efforts are
vetoed by the aggressor or those who
condone the aggressor it is necessary to
bring this issue to the attention of the
general assembly in the event of
two-thirds of the votes reflecting the
will of Nations from Asia Africa Europe
both Americas and the Pacific region in
other words a global qualified majority
The veto should be effectively overcome
and such resolution of the general
assembly must be legally binding for all
member states the Second Step the UN
Security Council must be fully
accountable to the nations of the world
I welcome the proposals of various
leaders to expand the representation of
nations in the security Council the
composition of the permanent members of
the security Council should reflect the
current realities the realities and
Justice Ukraine considers it's unjust
when billions of people do not have
their permanent representation in the
security Council the African Unity must
be here permanently Asia deserves
broader permanent representation it can
not be considered normal when Nations
like Japan India for the Islamic World
remains outside the permanent membership
of the security Council one should take
into account the changes that have
taking place in Europe notably that
Germany has become one of the key Global
guaranas of peace and security this is a
fact it is also a matter of fact that
Germany deserves a place among the
permanent members of the security
Council Latin America must be
represented here permanently and the
Pacific States as well however we should
not confine or attention to those in top
seats only there is a need to expand the
participation and access to the
activities of the UN Security Council
and its subsidiary bodies for all
members of the UN General Assembly who
are not recognized as aggressors at the
same time uh any participation of uh uh
the uh Security Council membership
should be suspended for a period of time
when such a state resorts to aggression
against another nation in violation of
the US chter the third step there is a
need for a system to prevent aggression
through early response to actions
violating territorial integrity and
sovereignty of states it is time to do
that the nations of the world should
agree on such a mechanism for responding
to aggressions to protect others that
everyone would want for their own
security the Russian invasion of Ukraine
has shown what can serve such a
mechanism and one other things powerful
sanctions against the aggressor not all
only at a stage when bcha has already
happened but also at the stage of the
buildup of the invasion Army anyone who
wants to start a war should see before
their fatal mistake what exactly they
will lose when the war would start the
issue of applying such preventive
sanctions should be automatically
submitted for consideration of the UN
Security Council when any member of the
UN General Assembly reports a threat of
aggression Ukrainian soldiers now are
doing at the expense of their blood what
the UN Security Council should do by its
voting they're stopping aggression and
upholding the principles of the UN
Charter and now U talking about the
territorial Integrity this is an element
of both the UN Charter and our peace
formula that is inextricably linked to
the issue of cleaning the territory from
the occupiers occupation is an an
exhaustible source of dynamite under the
international rule-based order so I will
provide examples of concrete steps that
to be taken for the security
architecture to be strong using Ukraine
as an example very specific things just
like ukrainians First Complete
withdrawal of all Russian troops and
Military formations including the
Russian Black Sea Fleet or its leaky
remnants as well as the withdrawal of
all mercenaries and Par military
formations of Russia from the entire
sovereign territory of Ukraine within
our International recognized borders as
of 1991 second full restoration of
Ukraine's effective control over the
entire state border and exclusive
economic zone including the black and
ao's as well as in the carriage trait in
fact only the implementation of these
two points will result in an honest
reliable and complete cessation of
hostilities ladies and gentlemen reform
of such International institutions were
made
following tragedies following major Wars
we should not wait for the aggression to
be over we need to act now our
aspiration for peace should drive the
reform as I Was preparing the Ukrainian
peace formula I underpinned its points
by the principles of the UN Charter only
the principles of the UN Charter and
resolutions adopted by the general
assembly this is precisely what enables
uh the Ukrainian peace formula to to to
to become Global the Nations that engage
with the formula realize that they're
working for the rule-based international
order for the protection of territorial
integrity and Sovereign of States
protection of Human Rights prevention of
aggression and genocidal policy
naturally the epicenter of such efforts
should be in this very chamber the UN
Security Council chamber and and even to
the greater extent in the General
Assembly Hall if reform of un
institutions is necessary for that then
we should not be afraid of such reform
we are ready to work together with UN
members who have joined the peace
formula to work on relevant draft
resolutions and amendments to the UN
Charter and I would like to make it
clear for everyone in the world that
Ukraine is proposing while addressing to
nations of the world and calling them to
join the implementation of the peace
formula every country can demonstrate
its leadership within the framework of
one or more or maybe all points of the
peace
formula we can establish groups based on
the points of the peace formula where
National Security advisors to heads of
states and diplomatic Representatives
work now these groups are tusked to
elaborate a list of decisions and
legislative proposals to be implemented
in order for the relevant point of the
peace formula to be fulfilled we're
ready to hold u 10 conferences at the
level of
advisors uh and in accordance with the
10 points of the peace formula then uh a
summit on the level of leaders later
this drafts would be prepared uh and
submitted for consideration by heads of
States at the respective Summit thereby
all nations of the world that respect
peace can actively participate in
restoration of Peace cooperation is
always the key word for Ukraine in
international relations this word is
also key for peace so let us Let the
Peace Prevail May our
institutions and our cooperation be
stronger I thank you for your attention
and thank you for the possibility to
address you thank you for this
invitation thank you glory to
Ukraine I thank his uh Excellency
president zalinsky for for his briefing
and I shall now make a statement in my
capacity as the prime minister of the
Republic of
Albania Mr Secretary General
excellencies head of state and
governments distinguished
Representatives thank you all for being
here
today the presence of such considerable
number of dignitaries speaks to the very
high
importance of the issue at
hand thank you Secretary General for
your
remarks they
resonate with and reflect the values and
principles of our organization president
zalinski I'm grateful for your presence
here at such a tragic moment in your
country's history your strong words
translate the pain of your compatriots
and convey very clearly
together with your firm determination
the grit of your people and the
unwavering hope of your
nation excellencies while today the
world needs more than ever an acute
sense of
responsibility from all of us to
confront the multiple challenges and
threats facing our planet
conflicts unconstitutional seizures of
power climate change devast ing floods
and unforgiving droughts including
unpredictable and severe
wildfires what we witness instead is
more and more disruptive attitudes
Reckless acts and growing conflictuality
within and among states in many parts of
the world the examples of force have
proliferated while the force of example
has become a rarity who could have
imagined until not long ago that in the
third decade of the 21st century a
disastrous War started by a permanent
member of this Council would put Europe
at risk by brutally undermining all the
principles that gave birth to the United
Nations who could have imagined until
only few years ago that an unjustified
unjust and unprovoked Military
aggression of a big country
against the new democracy would not be
immediately promptly and universally
condemned by all the nations who gather
here and share the same goals and
principles how to understand the yes
but or calls on both
sides with arguments in order to avoid
calling a spade a spade and which refus
to call a brutal aggression
by its only and real name a man-made
tragedy that is inflicting Untold
suffering to the Ukrainian people but
also reverberating across World regions
hurting growth raising prices and
threatening with hunger and starvation
hundreds of millions of people an
aggression in the heart of Europe cannot
be Europe's problem only as some think
as some say or as some whisper cynics
may think that Ukraine is just a problem
dropped on the lap of the democratic
West to deal with and they even Mumble
that what goes around comes around
implying that this is a natural payback
for what might have happened before
elsewhere in other times is it really I
invite everyone to think twice this war
of aggression must be everyone's
business let me remind us by
paraphrasing the tragic account by
Martin
ner first they came for Georgia I did
not speak out then they came for Crimea
it was not my country so I did not speak
out then they came for the whole Ukraine
but I was not Ukrainian and I did not
speak out and then they came for me but
there was no one left to help and defend
me as we speak there have been more than
20 thou 26,000
civilians that have passed away tomorrow
the number will be higher and it will
increase every other day for as long as
this war
continues given the inexcusable nuclear
subur rattling that keeps coming time
and again from different layers of the
Kremlin one is right to fear that one
day God forbid this madness could turn
into something far worse and don't
forget as unimaginable today as this war
was
yesterday excellencies we have a duty to
help those in need and in this respect
Ukraine and ukrainians we may
defer of course we may defer on how to
support Ukraine in its fight for freedom
and dignity we may have different views
on how to end this war let's discuss
them but it would be an insult to the
intelligence of this
organization if we fail to unanimously
recognize and say loudly who is the
aggressor and who is the aggressed it is
the same sharp difference between War
and Peace as Tolstoy would remind you go
back and read
him if we fail to admit this Crystal
Clear truth we are not only letting down
Ukraine and its people we are failing
our core
responsibility compromising the future
and betraying all our children from
Brazil to Spain from the Arctic to the
southern
pole the struggle of Ukraine is also the
struggle of everyone who aspires to live
in a world where nations are free and
equal where territorial Integrity is
undisputable and their right to live in
peace is
unquestionable the contrary is not only
shortsighted but utterly dangerous for
everyone under this roof this is why
everyone has to do its
part Albania is a small country our
continued support to Ukraine may not
change the Dynamics on the
Battleground but it contributes to not
rewarding aggression to not accepting
annexation and not letting the obvious
become
dubious and again I repeat we may defer
on how to deal with this we may have
different views on how to go towards
peace but how possibly we can have
different views on who is the aggressor
and who is the
aggress
Excellence excellencies the main duty of
the Security Council is to act
decisively on behalf of the entire world
and in the service of the
world we can well understand those who
were many in number who asked ask what
is the security Council
doing the abusive use of the right to
veto
sadly has held the security Council
hostage it has paralyzed the council but
it has not reduced it to
silence as we can
see the proof is here in this meeting
the force of rules and values bring us
together they should not be replaced by
rules of
force
and the rejection of values the world is
dangerously uh tipping into what could
become a tragedy for all of us calling
the experience of the western Balkans we
have seen where the path of brutality
can lead to and the tremendous cost it
brings for all including for the
perpetrators history has confirmed that
those who saw War as a shortcut to
achieve their goals ended up regretting
it
forever Russia has tried many times to
use or better misuse the change reality
in the western Balkans particularly the
birth of the Republic of kosova to
justify their Neo Imperial dreams and
the subsequent nightmare they have
exported in
Ukraine no matter how hard one may cry
kosova whose Independence has been
sanctioned by the international court of
justice chapter
14 of this Charter of United
Nations International court of justice
cannot serve as a pretext for territory
grab or illegal
annexations if today lasting peace in
our region is Within Reach This has to
do first and foremost with the lesson
learned that the most efficient way to
overcome the past and shape a common
future is through cooperation not
through division by promoting free
movement of people Goods Services
capitals not by ra raising artificial
barrier by Building Bridges for our kids
to enjoy freedom and prosperity whatever
their language whatever their
race whatever their nationality
not erecting walls for our ghosts of the
past to seek and hide in Endless blame
games I'll end with this the Preamble of
the United Nation Charter calls on us to
practice tolerance and live together in
peace with one another as good neighbors
important decisions are never a matter
of chance they are always a matter of
choice Albania has made its choice to
stand for peace
development and progress to stand with
the aggressed not with the aggressors to
stand with and to stand for Ukraine
thank
you I resume now my function as
president of the council I now give the
floor to his Excellency Mr guermo lasso
mendosa constitutional president of the
Republic of
Ecuador so excellen
your Excellency Edie Rama prime minister
of the Republic of Albania and president
of the security
Council I would like to thank you for
your conduct of the security Council
during this
month it has been almost 19 months ukia
since the beginning of the war of
aggression against
Ukraine The Briefing provided by
Secretary General antoron
Gutierrez continues to appeal to the
Russian Federation to give peace an
opportunity this war cannot go on yet
another day the Russian Federation must
immediately suspend its military
operations in
accordance with the order of the
international court of justice the
ruling of that Court the
highest legal
system in the world on the 16th of March
2022 this prolonged war was initially
denied and was called a mere special
military operation in addition to
destroying Ukraine costing the lives of
thousands of people it is undermining
the very purposes and principles
enshrined in the United Nations Charter
in particular that of territorial
integrity at the origin of this
organization when this organization was
built we the peoples of the United
Nations determined to preserve and spare
future Generations from the scourge of
war and to that end to practice
tolerance and to coexist in peace as
Good Neighbors on that
basis the United Nations Charter was
built
it is unique Ecuador has said this
before and we would insist on this point
again today there is not a charter for
the South and another Charter for the
north nor is there a charter for the
west and one charter for the east in all
languages the content of the charter is
the same
it is one and indivisible there is not
one version in Russian and a different
version in Spanish in no
case is the use of
force to be used against the territorial
Integrity or the political independence
of a state or to be used in any way
which runs counter to the purposes of
the United Nations
how can we uphold the principles and
purposes of the UN
Charter for Effective multilateralism
and at the same time invade a
neighboring country or not condemn that
Invasion maintaining indifference or
complicity on the
contrary to defend the territorial
Integrity of
States means that we must respect and
implement the provisions of the UN
Charter we must maintain International
Peace and
security not to aggress a third state
and to abstain from voting in disputes
where we're a
party there are those who say that the
crisis of peace and
security is due to supposed shortcomings
in the charter but no
reform no new international framework
will be
sufficient for peace and
security if states are not determined to
respect and Implement these higher
principles what a fatal blow for
multilateralism to have a military
invasion of a neighboring country this
War which has
impacted the Dynamics and the work done
in this Security Council continues to
undermine trust in the UN
system
however beyond the difficulties which
this body is
facing to have a clearcut response to
this issue we must underscore the
enormous contribution of the United
Nations for millions of peoples and
humanitarian groups working on the
ground providing emergency assistance in
particular to women and children I
recognize the efforts of the Secretary
General in the humanitarian
sphere
including in the Black Sea grain
initiative and we ask that that
initiative be resumed Mr President
distinguished
colleagues there are corrosive
narratives which claim to justify this
war but there is no
justification with any Legal Foundation
we have been told for example that the
invasion of Ukraine is in response to a
supposed uh group of countries of the
West aiming to weaken Russia we've been
told that Russia is acting in
self-defense in the face of anti-russian
policies with regard to some inhabitants
or against Russian
culture but what greater Act of
xenophobia or disregard for one's
neighbor than to carry out a war against
one's neighbor
there's little truth
in that position we need only look at
the pattern of voting in the general
assembly when
resolutions have been adopted on the
territorial Integrity of Ukraine with a
vast clear majority of
course there is
no veto which can halt the force of the
general assembly when it comes to defend
ending the territorial Integrity of its
members and this majority is not a
majority of alliances or Partnerships as
some
claim Ecuador rejects any Invasion
regardless of the country committing
that Invasion moreover and in particular
if that country holds a permanent seat
in this body the Secretary General Bros
Scali
affirmed that only a power can impose
order on
chaos it is the power of principles
which transcend changing perceptions of
coexistence in the short
term ladies and
gentlemen among the hundreds of
thousands of people who have fled War
there were
some there were many many ecuadorians
many of them had to flee through
Emergency Operations with a support team
out of Ukraine and into neighboring
countries these people were some of the
first people impacted by the serious
humanitarian Fallout of this
Invasion which continues to wors and
millions of people are now forced to
leave their
homes they have been uh the hardest hit
primarily women girls and boys are the
ones who are hardest hit this war has
continued to have a global impact as
well it has exacerbated the nuclear
threat it has led to Global Food
insecurity and it has impacted economies
in particular the economies of
developing countries for all of these
reasons we appeal to the members of the
security
Council individually and collectively to
redouble our support so that the efforts
and the good offices of the Secretary
General
can be played out on the humanitarian
and political fronts so that we can work
towards
just peace based on territorial
integrity and on the principles of the
UN Charter immediately thank you very
much thank
you thanks to his Excellency Mr lasso
mosa for his statement I now give the
floor to his Excellency Mr Nadu Dana
akufo
Ada president of the Republic of Ghana
Mr President I thank you for making me a
part of this important
meeting on how we can uphold better the
purposes and principles of the United
Nations
Charter with the unfortunate tragic
events in Ukraine serving as the
backdrop I'm grateful to Secretary
General Antonio gutterz for making a
compelling case of the shared benefits
we derive as members States when we
choose to be peaceloving as required by
the
charter Mr President none of us here in
this chamber can claim not to be aware
that our world is in a troubled
place the sharp differences in
geopolitical competition among major
powers and the intense convergence of
the crisis in the world particularly of
conflicts climate change
inequality unconstitutional change of
government and unsustainable development
have undermined Global trust and
solidarity and unraveled the common
logic that has prevailed since
1945 which is it is better to suffer the
inadequacies of the multilateral system
for the greater good than to pursue the
chaos of the unknown for National
advantage in this context and being
mindful full of the reality that neither
Geographic boundaries nor political
ideologies have been able to isolate any
state from the burden of the prevailing
crisis Ghana continues to Hope in
Earnest for an end to the war against
Ukraine and for the construction of a
future marked by peaceful
coexistence Mutual cooperation and
brotherly relations between the two
neighboring countries
indeed the Russian federation's
aggression against Ukraine is plainly
wrong have said so on many
platforms the war has had an
increasingly devastating toll on the
people of Ukraine and the rest of the
world particularly for those of us in
Africa and has challenged our shared
values of International Peace and
security the timings of the war have
constrained Collective efforts in
reintegrating
multilateralism and impeded common
approaches to confront effectively
several complex challenges of our
time for those of us in Ghana however
the unfolding situation is not a lost
cause whilst we're rightfully distressed
by what is happening around us we
believe that together we can still
mitigate the challenges of the unknown
if we are prepared to cooperate for a
peaceful careful managed process of the
reform of global institutions that would
red would redistribute fairly
responsibilities and authority to
reflect the present realities of our
world we also believe that history has a
lesson to teach and the painful lessons
of the two previous world wars Inspire
the solemn commitments made by by the
founders of the United Nations to
refrain from the use of force in their
relations among
states that common understanding to
replace force and might with the rule of
law cooperation and the peaceful
settlement of disputes underpins the
purposes and principles of the United
Nations Charter and remains valid if we
are to avoid a hsian state of affairs in
Interstate relations
we must thus work together strongly to
reverse the growing fragmentation of our
world and the elevation of nationalist
ideologies and actions above commonly
accepted
rules violation of sovereignty and
territorial Integrity of states and
attempts to normalize such violations or
selectively apply the rules of
international law and the charter would
only undermine the promise of the past
and the hope of the for future
Generations it is in this regard that
Ghana continues to be a firm advocate
for dialogue and diplomacy in resolving
the Russian war against
Ukraine we do not do so because of a
want of because of want of a
resolution of the dispute at any cost
but United in our belief with many
others we believe the only pathway for a
comprehensive peaceful and sustainable
resolution of the dispute is one that
must be just and based on the chter of
the United Nations and international
law in taking a principal position on
the conflict in Ukraine Ghan has been
concerned about the ramifications of the
war on the global community and
multilateralism we therefore welcome the
opportunity that the new agenda for
peace provides which is to reset our
common understanding on how among others
we relate with each other as
states can reinforce the preemptory
Norms of international law that have
provid as stability for almost eight
decades and find new ways of addressing
old challenges that continue to
undermine States and the sovereignty of
Nations Mr President in resp in support
of the choices we need to make for
renewed and inclusive in
multilateralism I would want to share
three key
messages
firstly many of the organs and
institutions established by the charter
such as for the security Council
continue to be relevant but the
council's composition and working
methods need renew through the
completion of the long outstanding
reforms in support of the common African
position on Security Council
reforms contained in the aini
consensus Ghana urges the
transformation of the dialogue among
member states to Envision end point that
delivers a security Council that is
representative and which also addresses
the historical Injustice done the
continent of
Africa to overcome naughty discussions
around the veto we encourage the ongoing
efforts to limit its use and the
subsequent placement of a moratorium on
its use that will lead progressively to
its removal over a reasonable period of
time we cannot continue to have a
security Council that is structurally
limited from being effective and yet
demands Universal acceptance for its
decisions as well many other things in
life with changes we need to adapt and
with authority comes a responsibility
that must be kept secondly the Peace of
the world is indivisible and integrated
with all other Global Arrangements
beyond our collective security our
efforts of preventive diplomacy must be
comprehensive and
broad-based we need to be aware that for
instance enemal economic and financial
policies have an enduring impact on
peace
and that Global policies in the
structure and functioning of
international institutions cannot remove
the centrality of peace from their rais
on death we must strengthen in a
comprehensive and integrated manner our
efforts in preventing the outbreak of
violence or Resurgence of new
conflicts thirdly and finally
multilateralism at the global level must
be accompanied by effective Regional
Partnerships Partnerships that help to
anticipate better threats to our common
Humanity which prioritize specific means
for resolving differences and which cuts
across regions to enhance its
Effectiveness when required when we fail
to leverage fully the potential of
regional bodies we could only have
ourselves to blame when multilateral
efforts at the global level are unable
to deliver
in ending I call again for peace in
Ukraine and emphasize as my delegation
has often done in this Council that
there's no alternative to winning the
peace in Ukraine we hope the council can
help this United Nations to assume an
enhanced role in support of Peace
efforts around the world but in
particular in Ukraine for the benefit of
All Peoples Mr President I thank you for
your
Indulgence I think he Excellency Mr Aku
for his statement and now I give the
floor to his Excellency Mr alen
B president of the Swiss
Federation thank you very much Mr
President thank you first and foremost
for organizing this debate and I also
wish to take this opportunity to thank
the Secretary General of the United
Nations for his remarks but beyond his
remarks I wish to thank him for his
steadfast unstinting commit m to the
advancement of Peace the advancement of
dialogue and especially when it is most
difficult excellencies ladies and
gentlemen first of all the facts and
they are not positive the times we live
in are marked by the questioning of
multilateralism the multiplication of
conflict conflicts and the deepening of
inequalities and uh there's a question
where's our responsibility where does
our respons responsibility our shared
responsibility lie our responsibility we
who have convened here at the very
minimum that is to recall the essential
principles enshrined in the chart of the
United Nations I had a a copy here of
course and to fulfill the Mandate which
has been entrusted to us this core text
expresses our desire our shared desire
the shared desire of All Peoples to live
in peace and the text is a guarantor of
universal values the overarching
principles of multilateral order
Sovereign equality of states and uh a
Prohibition on the use of force defense
of Human Rights including economic
social progress for people and in this
war as we know War the suffering of
civilians is a common denominator it is
always civilian
suffering and international humanitarian
law
and imposes obligations upon us and upon
all parties to conflict as you aware
Swiss is a depository of the Geneva
conventions we are faithful to the
long-standing tradition in this regard
and we are very much staunchly
determined to uphold it and to ensure
respect for international humanitarian
law and uh as members of the council we
have committed to commit and in
implement this clear unique mandate
conferred Upon Us by the charter of the
United Nation conferred upon all of us
here namely the maintenance of
International Peace and
security with Russia's military
aggression against Ukraine the charter
has been violated at a large scale on a
massive scale yet session after session
Russia a permanent member of this
Council has been denying its
responsibility its responsibility for
for the thousands of dead and wounded in
Ukraine its responsibility for the
millions of displaced persons and
finally it's responsibility for all
those
plunged into deep insecurity wherever
they are in the world including
incidentally in Russia the consequences
of this war distinguished colleagues
ladies and gentlemen the consequences of
this war are planetary in nature Global
Food security has been undermined the
energy sector has been disrupted nuclear
risks are increasing inequalities are
growing
Switzerland demands that the Russian
Federation respect the charter that it
respect its principles and once again we
call upon the Russian Federation to
cease hostilities to withdraw its troops
from Ukrainian territory and respect the
sovereignty and territorial Integrity of
Ukraine ladies and gentlemen while the
Mandate of the Security Council is
clear
it is not always as effective as it
should be as one would desire while the
objective is to save lives guarantee
Global Security reinforced stability our
discussions are bogged down on issues
that fail to produce tangible results on
certain issues this Council must not
squander the most precious asset at its
disposal the trust of those who rely on
it to work to guarantee them a life in
dignity and peace and we have the means
to fulfill this mandate as has been
Illustrated in the 26 resolutions that
the security Council has adopted since
the month of January these are
resolutions that are geared towards
promoting peace and Security in Colombia
in Afghanistan in Iraq and in South
Sudan and these
examples are really there to show us
that the security Council even though so
it is more difficult than in the past
has retained its capacity for action of
course there's a need an urgent need for
reform in Switzerland has been committed
for a number of years to Greater and
better representation beginning with the
African countries committed also to
better working methods and yet we are
all aware of the fact that no reform can
replace the will of states to respect
the
charter in the new agenda for peace the
Secretary General has indicated further
steps forward to step up our action and
multilateralism to uh strengthen our to
close ranks around the principles of
universality of solidarity and trust and
we have been assuming this duty of
solidarity in Ukraine we are committed
to alleviating the suffering of the
civilian population rendering Justice to
the victims promoting
a political solution to the conflict in
due time we have opened our doors to
people fleeing the war we have been
delivering humanitarian Aid we have been
collaborating with the Ukrainian
government on the process of
reconstruction and the challenges the
tasks Fad in Ukraine facing Ukraine are
immense to give just one example an area
four times four times the size of
Switzerland Switzerland is not a large
country four times the large size of
Switzerland that is the territory of
Ukraine which has been contaminated with
mines and there too we have been
supporting humanitarian de mining with
our knowhow and with deliveries of
equipment and a commitment that we will
continue to shore up and it is in the
same Spirit of solidarity that we are
calling for the relaunching of the Black
Sea initiative we wish to take this
opportunity to express our gratitude to
the Secretary General for his tireless
efforts in this regard excellencies
distinguished
colleagues multilateralism is the only
option the only option to achieve peace
the only way to move away from
individualistic thinking in which each
side seeks only to defend their own
interest to maximize their own influence
the only option to relaunch the search
for common Sustainable Solutions that
guarantee a dignified life for all and
against this backdrop in this Spirit
Switzerland welcomes de diplomatic
initiatives in favor of a lasting peace
in Ukraine a peace rooted in the
principles of the charter of the United
Nations the charter which is truly the
Cornerstone of peaceful coexistence of
all
states in the past and
today threats isolationism isolationism
violence have never provided answers to
the dysfunctions and imbalances of the
world in which we live and this Council
secured Council can only successfully
fulfill its mandate therefore Implement
uh to therefore uh ensure the common
desire of all people of this world to
live in peace and SEC security to be
made a reality only to can can it
achieve this if it acts in spirit of
trust and
collaboration this Spirit needs uh this
Spirit must guide everyone around this
table today we have an opportunity to
reverse course to change the situation
we have this opportunity but there's a
need for will to be there for Ardent
will to be there because a lasting peace
is worth more than any fleeting G thank
you Excellency Mr B for his statement
and now I give the floor to his
Excellency Mr fumio kishida Prime
Minister of
Japan Mr President at the
outset I would like to commend the
leadership of the Albanian prime
minister prime minister Rama for
convening this high level security
council meeting on multilateralism and
the situation in Ukraine I also welcome
the participation of President zalinsky
of Ukraine today the international order
based on the rule of law is facing an
unprecedented crisis and challenge it is
the charter of the United Nations that
is the foundation of international order
the charter provides that the security
Council has primary responsibility for
the maintenance of International Peace
and security we all gathered here
today because of the infringement of the
rule of law by one of the permanent
members of this very
Council Mr
President I visited q and bua in March
of this year and also went to the sites
of the tragedies I will will never
forget the heartbreaking feelings I had
at that time I renew my determination
that Japan stands with
Ukraine we condemn in the strongest
terms Russia's aggression against
Ukraine which is a clear violation of
international law including the UN
Charter the aggression Must Be Stopped
immediately and the troops must be
withdrawn right now now and
unconditionally any attempt to
unilaterally change the peacefully
established status of territories by
force or coion must not be tolerated
anywhere in the
world irresponsible nuclear rhetoric the
deployment of nuclear weapons in
bellarus and the occupation and
militarization of zapor nuclear power
plant pose a threat to world peace and
stability Russia's nuclear threats let
alone its use of nuclear weapons are
unacceptable abuse of the veto power
toct the decisions of the security
Council and undermine its credibility
cannot be accepted by the International
Community Mr
President Russia's aggression against
Ukraine
has exacerbated concerns over a rule of
lawlessness around the world we must not
allow the creation of a second or third
Ukraine it is essential to achieve a
comprehensive just and Lasting peace in
Ukraine conforming to the principles of
the UN Charter in order to protect an
international order based on the rule of
law Japan supports president zelinsky's
sincere efforts to uphold the basic
principles of the United Nations Charter
in his peace
formula in Hiroshima in May I myself
together with leaders of a wide range of
countries including Ukraine affirmed the
importance of the principles of the
charter including respect for
sovereignty and territorial integrity
and the peaceful resolution of the
disputes following these discussions two
meetings of National Security advisers
on Ukraine were
held Japan welcomes the participation of
many countries including the so-called
Global South and will continue to make a
positive
contribution Mr
President we must not forget that the
aggression against Ukraine has caused
serious problems such as refugees food
and energy insecurity and threats to
nuclear safety and has led to suffering
for many people around the
world Japan is committed to working
together with other nations to promote
efforts to support The Afflicted
people Japan strives to promote human
centered International cooperation
overcoming differences in regimes and
values in order to protect human dignity
Mr
President there has never been a time
when effective multilateralism the theme
of today's debate is more needed than
now we must overcome numerous calamities
including the aggression against Ukraine
and realize
multilateralism rooted in a spirit of
solidarity bearing this in mind I myself
have engaged in a series of discussions
with leaders of various countries Japan
has also organized Security Council open
debate on the rule of law and
peacebuilding during our Council
presidency to listen to the diverse
voices of the International
Community Japan will further strengthen
its effort to resolve issues concerning
International Peace and security
including through preventive diplomacy
while upholding the rule of law under
multilateralism Mr
President now is the time to return to
the unshakable principles that we the
member states have built up since
1945 including the United Nations
Charter and work toward a world of
coroporation
not Division and
confrontation to this end strengthening
the functions of the UN is an urgent
task the security Council must be
enlarged in both its permanent and
non-permanent seats to better reflect
the realities of today's world including
Africa we must now take concrete action
looking ahead to the summit of the
future and the 80th anniversary of the
establishment of the United Nations it
is time to move forward to realize that
you and as a platform that listens to
people facing difficulties and works
with them to confront challenges
together aiming for a world that
respects human dignity thank you for
your attention I thank his Excellency Mr
kishida for his statement and I now give
the floor to his Excellency Mr Robert
Abella prime minister of the Republic of
Malta thank you Eddie Mr President Mr
Secretary General dear colleagues
excellencies and also dear friends first
of all I would like to kick off by
thanking the Albanian presidency for
having organized this high level open
debate of the security Council I also
thank the Secretary General for sharing
his thoughts with us earlier today 12
years ago soon after the outbreak of the
Arab Spring Malta had launch Ed its bid
to serve on the security Council that
was a time I remember of turmoil also
instability in our immediate
neighborhood but also it was a time of
Hope and
aspirations the decision to embark on
this journey stemmed from our commitment
to the principles enshrined in the
United Nations Charter they are Timeless
and also Universal and an integral part
of our foreign policy our unwaver belief
is that multilateralism today's Major
team that we are discussing holds the
answer to contemporary challenges and
that all countries should engage
proactively to this end and this served
as our Point of Departure way back today
as elected members of this Council this
these convictions continue to serve as
our Guiding Light Mr President more than
ever the world today needs an effective
multilateral system with the United
Nations at its
core we must redouble our efforts to
uphold and also defend the fundamental
principles that unite us we must promote
our common values at a time when they
are being aggressively undermined and
threatened we must protect them and
adequately respond to any contempt for
these values at the the same time we
must not lose sight of the fact that we
are living in a world where conflicts
unfortunately are on the rise the
nuclear threat still looms the climate
crisis is unfortunately spiraling out of
control democracy and human rights are
under a systematic attack Global
inequalities are deepening
disinformation and misinformation
campaigns are feeding as well
as amplifying tensions no country by
itself can tackle these complex and
existential challenges they require our
full and Collective attention effective
multilateralism is the only Avenue to
address these challenges in a decisive
and holistic manner Mr President if we
are to reach these ambitious goals we
cannot resign ourselves to living in a
world where might is right last year the
Russian Federation began its aggression
against the Ukraine violating its
sovereignty and also its territorial
Integrity these acts constitute a a
blatant violation of the United Nations
Charter and also a violation of
international law they were
overwhelmingly deplored and rejected by
the general assembly who had called for
for Russia's immediate withdrawal of its
military forces and the cessation of
hostilities this war profoundly
undermines the multilateral system it
weakens and also destabilizes this very
Council the immediate and long-term
consequences of such actions by
permanent member of council cannot be
emphasized enough and on the occasion of
this debate I reiterate malta's full
support
for Ukraine's Independence sovereignty
and territorial Integrity within its
International recognized borders I
equally underline Ukraine's inherent
right to self-defense as enshrined in
article 51 of the United Nations Charter
Ukrainian people have paid the heaviest
price as a result of this unjustified
and unprovoked War of aggression it has
led to another human-made catastrophe as
the world was still struggling to find
the path to normality following a Clic
coid pandemic all wars are indeed
devastating and this is of course no
exception lost lives are gone forever
and will never be recovered the scars of
those wounded injured and traumatized by
conflict never fully heal once the
fighting is over the road to recovery
will still be a long and arduous one
through its sections Russia did not only
bring War back to Europe's Shores it
also generated a global food crisis that
has seriously impacted mostly developing
countries around the world and while the
Black Sea grain initiative allowed
almost 33 million people 33 million tons
of grain to Bish shied R Russia's
unilateral decision to pull out of the
deal has seen grain prices unfortunately
sore up again I once again State m us
here uncompromising position that using
hunger and Food Supplies as weapons of
war is completely unacceptable in
closing Mr President I reiterate and
emphasize once again that there can be
no peace in our future if the strong can
trample on the weak there can be no
peace if international law can be brush
as side if geopolitical interests so
demand there can be no peace if the
rights of states and individuals can be
suspended or revoked at any time malta's
commitment to peace dialogue and
multilateralism remain as strong as ever
we remain firm in our resolve to stay at
the Forefront of the defense of the
United Nations Charter no matter how
difficult or disheartening circumstances
may seem we must never give up on peace
we must never give up on dialogue and we
simply cannot afford to do so in this
time of upheaval our Collective reply is
to redouble and redouble and redouble
our efforts and continue to invest in
our multilateral system in doing so we
must also reform this Council to make
sure it is truly fit for purpose in
today's world a council that is more
transparent more effective more
representative more accountable and also
more democratic meanwhile we remain
convinced that the only the only step
towards a lasting peace in Ukraine is
for Russia to immediately seize all
hostilities it must unconditionally
withdraw all its forces and also its
military equipment from the entire
territory of Ukraine within its
internationally recognized borders thank
you I thank his Excellency Mr Abella for
his
statement I now give the floor to his
Excellency Mr Ron Dona prime minister of
Mr President I thank the UN Secretary
General for his enlightening briefing on
the terrible conditions and the Fallout
of the war in
Ukraine 19 months after the outbreak of
War since the beginning of hostilities
in Ukraine my country has expressed its
opposition to the war and condemned
the violation of Ukraine's territorial
Integrity we have unequivocally
reaffirmed the principles of the UN
Charter as the underpinning of our
coexistence above all Gabon has
tirelessly called for an immediate ceas
fire and for negotiations in good faith
between the parties to be taken up in
order to silence the
weapons 570 days since the beginning of
this deadly War the shock wave
has continued to spread beyond the
borders of Ukraine millions of people
have been forced to flee within Ukraine
and millions more are now refugees
Beyond National
borders deaths are counted in the
thousands while indiscriminate shelling
continues to Target essential
infrastruct structure
structures not sparing nuclear power
plants plants Bridges hydroelectric dams
schools or hospitals in the path and the
nuclear threat has become even more
widespread the International System in
particular the agricultural sector as
well as many value chains continue to
suffer from The Fallout of this
conflict this has worsened the global
humanitarian toll by sewing hunger
precariousness despair
and fear but also invisible wounds such
as hatred and the rejection of others as
we assess this situation it is not clear
whether or not the trauma suffered by
children women and men exposed to the
horrors of War will be reflected in the
final tally of this conflict on this
point we wonder how much
horror must be suffered before
deescalation is finally considered Ed
how much Terror must be sown before the
Waring parties agree to sit down to talk
Mr
President since the outset of
hostilities every rostrom in the United
Nations has been the stage for
accusations and for
opposition they have not provided relief
or remedy for those who have fallen in
the trenches or who have been crushed
under the debris in the battlefields and
in the cities and Villages of
Ukraine an alternative to war is
possible and it must be found in
existing channels outlined in the UN
Charter and in relevant resolutions of
this Council without delay we must
reconcile with the spirit of the UN
Charter its Beating Heart Is Our common
determination to spare present and
future Generations from the scourge of
War my my country reiterates its appeal
to the parties to negotiate in good
faith in order to put an end to this war
we call on the parties to show restraint
and
responsibility everything must be done
to ensure
deescalation and to create conditions
which will allow for
diplomacy gapon Gabon is convinced that
any unilateral action which further
Deadlocks the situation hardens
positions and fuels antagonisms must be
ruled out I reiterate my country's
opposition to war opposition to the war
in Ukraine but opposition to any war in
the world in particular the many chronic
and cyclical wars in Africa rejecting
the mindset of war is not fleeing War
nor nor is it a sign of cowardice or an
opportunist stance we must draw from the
indelible lessons of the history of
unjust Wars which have been hammered
home that the the fact that those who
cause provoke or maintain these wars are
rarely the winners beyond the criminal
responsibility which can be established
the tribunal of History will be
uncompromising and that is why we reject
this mindset of War we must uphold the
noble ideals of the United Nations my
country has a long-standing tradition of
Peace which has never let us
down we had to take existential choices
about our future we've always been able
to opt for peace and we continue to
defend this ideal which we believe is an
imperative because the war runs counter
to the values which underpin this
organization and the security Council
every day of War brings into question
our calling our mandate and our
credibility in conclusion I would like
to work together with the parties to
help restore peace in Ukraine because we
stand for peace in Ukraine we support
the process of peace and dialogue and
every initiative which aims to activate
the channels of diplomacy and to silence
the weapons in Ukraine is a good thing
we support the initiatives for peaceful
coexistence between Russia and Ukraine
thank
you I thank his Excellency mronga first
statement for to his Excellency the
right honorable Oliver toden member of
Parliament deputy prime minister of the
United Kingdom of Great Britain and
Northern
Ireland thank you president I am proud
to sit here today in solidarity with
President
zelinski he and the Ukrainian people
have met Russia's invasion of their
country with bravery and with courage I
pay tribute to their
fortitude Ukraine's fight against
against Russian aggression is not only a
fight for Freedom it is also a fight for
the principles upon which the United
Nations itself is based principles
underpinned by our Charter which says
that all state sovereignty is equal that
territorial Integrity is
inviolable that disputes should be
settled
peacefully and that we must protect
those things
together when Russia's tanks rolled into
Ukraine they trampled over every single
one of those principles they have done
so ever since every missile every bomb
every false arrest every piece of
propaganda has been a flagrant assault
not only on freedom but on our
multilateral rules based system if we
allow Russia to lay waste to what we
have built
here the risks to world order the risks
to us all are
grave for over a year and a half Ukraine
has been suffering the terrible
consequences of Russia's war of choice
we must never forget the human cost
9,500 people killed
177,000 people injured reports of half a
million military casualties on both
sides Russia has callously targeted
schools hospitals even
playgrounds ukrainians have been
tortured and they have been raped men
women and thousands of children have
been forcibly deported from their
homes and the devast station flows
Beyond Ukraine's borders thanks to their
destruction of thousands of tons of
grain the hungry and malnourished people
of the developing world are Russia's
victims too that is why the United
Kingdom will contribute a further £3
million to the world food program to
continue president zelinsky's grain from
Ukraine
initiative of course the only way to end
this widespread suffering is through a
just and Lasting peace Ukraine has
demonstrated their commitments to peace
time and time again including in
Copenhagen and in jeda this summer but
they have also shown on the battlefield
this Summer that they are capable of
restoring the sovereignty and
territorial Integrity that must be the
foundations of any peace Ukraine's
counter offensive has put Russia under
pressure
in total Ukraine has regained 50% of the
territory seized since the War Began and
in kiv and kazon the yellow and blue
flag flies high once again that flag
flies throughout the rest of the world
reflecting the solidarity we feel to
Ukraine yet we may wonder what
difference does this support make
when Russia seems so impervious to
United Nations demands when it seeks to
fuel its aims with arms from sanctioned
states such as Iran and the
dprk and when it conducts sham elections
in Ukraine's own Sovereign
territory the truth is this Russia knows
the power of collective action because
it tries so hard to weaken and divide
the international
community so just as we need to confront
our biggest challenges on global poverty
on climate change on artificial
intelligence
collectively we need effective
multilateralism to achieve resolution to
seek Justice For The Many Many victims
to rebuild ruined cities and create new
opportunities to get grain exports
flowing again to help put Ukraine back
on the path to
prosperity to secure peace and that is
what we shall do together thank you Mr
President I thank his Excellency the
right honorable doden for his statement
I now give the floor to his Excellency
Mr Antony blinkin secretary of state of
the United States of America thank you
very
much Mr Prime Minister thank you for
focusing the security Council on this
critically important issue and Mr
Secretary General thank you for the
moral Clarity that you've shown in
dealing with Russia's war against
Ukraine uh we're grateful to have been
able to welcome president zinsky uh to
this Council table and we thank him we
thank him for reminding us yesterday
today and every day what's at stake in
this conflict not just for Ukraine not
just for ukrainians but for all of
us fellow council
members two weeks ago I was in yid a
small Ukrainian town about 2 hours north
of
keev Russian forces seized the village
in the first days of the
invasion they went door too rounding up
residents at
gunpoint marching them to the local
elementary school where Russian soldiers
had set up a command
post then then soldiers forced more than
300 civilians mostly women children and
elderly people into a basement not fit
for human
habitation just a few small rooms no
windows no circulation no running
water the soldiers held residents there
for 28 straight days using them as human
Shields before fleeing when Ukrainian
Defenders arried to liberate the
town in ydney two residents took me into
the basement where they and others had
been
imprisoned my gu said that they were
packed together so tightly that they
could barely
breathe there was no room to sit let
alone lie
down when they cried out to their
captors that people were sick and needed
Medical Care a Russian soldier yelled
back let them
die my guide pointed to two handwritten
lists on of names on the basement
wall one was for the villagers that
Russian forces had
executed the other for the people who
died in the basement the oldest victim
was 93 years old the youngest 6 weeks
old the Russians only allowed the
removal of bodies once a day so children
parents husbands and wives were forced
to spend hours next to the corpse of
their loved
ones I begin here because from the
comfortable distance of this chamber
it's really easy to lose sight of what
it's like for Ukrainian victims of
Russian
aggression this is what happened in just
one building in one
community in
Ukraine there are so many others like
it in the last week alone Russia's bomb
Department buildings in uh Frey re it's
burned down humanitarian Aid Depots in
Lviv it's demolished grain silos in Essa
it shelled eight communities in sui in a
single
day this is what Ukrainian families are
living through every
day what they've experienced for 574
days of this full-scale Invasion it's
what they'll endure tomorrow and the day
after that for as long as Russia wages
his vicious
War a war that President Putin openly
declared from the outset
is aimed at erasing Ukraine from the map
as a sovereign country and restoring
Russia's Lost
Empire in this war there is an aggressor
and there is a
victim one side is attacking the core
principles of the UN Charter the other
fights to defend
them for over a year and a half Russia
has shredded the major tenants of the
United Nations Charter the universal
Declaration of Human Rights
International humanitarian law and
flouted One Security Council resolution
after
another let's
review first Russia's Invasion itself
violates the central pillar of the UN
Charter respect for the sovereignty and
territorial Integrity of all
Nations second Russia is committing war
crimes and crimes against humanity in
Ukraine on an almost daily
basis third Russia continues to engage
in Reckless nuclear saber rattling
announcing that it's stationing nuclear
weapons in berus and continuing to use
Europe's biggest nuclear power plant and
its employees as a shield for its
aggression risking catastrophic
consequences fourth Russia is
weaponizing hunger thanks to the Black
Sea grain initiative brokered by the
Secretary General and Tura approximately
33 million metric tons of grain reached
Global markets driving down food prices
around the world nearly 2third of the
wheat exported through that deal went to
developing
countries not only did Putin pull out of
the deal but Russia is now mining
Ukraine's Fields bombing its ports and
rails burning its
silos as a result Ukraine's wheat
exports will likely Fall by 2.8 million
metric tons this year that is the
equivalent of 5 A5 billion 5 a half
billion loaves of bread trapped in the
world's Bread Basket Russia meanwhile on
track for a record year of grain
exports the hungrier the world is the
more Moscow
profits fifth Russia is using Iranian
drones to to attack Ukrainian civilians
drones that Russia procured from Iran in
violation of Security Council resolution
2231 finally just last week Russia
hosted North Korean dictator Kim
Jong-un Putin said that they discussed
ways to cooperate
militarily while Kim pledged the dprk
and I quote full and unconditional
support end quote for Russia's war of
aggression of course the transfer of
arms between Moscow and pongyang would
violate multiple resolutions of this
Council it's hard to imagine a country
demonstrating more contempt for the
United Nations and all that it stands
for this from a country with a permanent
seat on this
Council President Putin is betting that
if he keeps doubling down on the
violence that if he's willing to inflict
enough suffering on enough
people the world will cave on its
principles and Ukraine will stop
defending
itself but ukrainians are not giving up
for they've seen what life would look
like if they submit to Russian
control it's that basement in yid
it's families having their children torn
away from them and deported to Russia
children taken away from their parents
and deported far away it's the rubble of
marapole it's the mass Graves of
bcha we are not giving up
either indeed since we were last here a
growing number of countries have come
together to try to forge a different way
forward in June over a dozen countries
met with Ukraine in Copenhagen to
discuss the path toward a just and
Lasting peace one that upholds the
United Nations Charter and its core
principles two months later more than 40
countries including many members of this
Council carried forward that discussion
with Ukraine and Jetta president Linsky
has put forward a 10-point plan for such
a piece President Putin has put forward
nothing now some argue that continuing
to stand with Ukraine and holding Russia
accountable distracts us from addressing
other priorities like confronting the
climate crisis expanding Economic
Opportunity strengthening health
systems that is a false choice we can
and we must do both we are doing
both we must work together to tackle the
global challenges that that are
affecting our people meet the
sustainable development goals invest in
a world where all people have an
opportunity to reach their full
potential the United States is the
world's leading contributor to these
efforts and as President Biden told the
general assembly yesterday we will
continue to do more than our share to
answers the answer the imperatives of
our time at the same time as President
Biden has made clear we must continue to
shore up the pillars of peaceful
relations among nations without which we
will be unable to achieve any of our
goals that's why we must send a clear
message not only to Russia Russia but to
all would be
aggressors that we will stand up not
stand by when the rules that we all
agreed to are being
challenged not only to prevent conflict
instability and suffering but to lay the
foundation for all that we can do to
improve people's lives in times of
peace I open by sharing the horrors that
I saw in
ydney let me close by telling you what
else I saw that day in
Ukraine I saw volunteers rebuilding
homes that had been raised by Russian
bombs Farmers harvesting Fields people
reopening businesses citizens clearing
mines and unexploded ordinance children
returning to
schools in short I saw a nation
rebuilding and reaiming its
future that is the right of all members
of our United Nations
that's what we defend when we stand up
for the international order the right of
people not only to survive but to thrive
to write their own
future our people Ukraine's people the
people of all Nations get to write their
own future we cannot we will not let one
man write that future for us thank
you I thinkk his Excellency Mr blinkin
for his statement and now I give the
floor to his Excellency Mr Sergey lavro
Minister for foreign affairs of the
Russian
Federation Mr President Mr Secretary
General
colleagues the existing International
order was based on the ruins and
following the Colossal tragedy of the
second world war its basis was the chart
of the United Nations became the chart
of the United Nations the key source of
modern international law largely thanks
to it the thanks the United Nations a
new world war was averted a new world
war which was fought with natural uh
nuclear disaster unfortunately after the
end of the Cold War the collective West
led by the US uh single-handedly decided
that it would determine fates of all of
humankind and with its complex of
superiority began to more frequently and
broadly ignore the legacy of the
founding fathers of the United Nations
today the W West turns to selectively to
Norms and principles
from on a case-by casee basis
exclusively based on their parochial
geopolitical needs this as resulted in a
shaking of global stability as well as
the exacerbation and the fermenting of
new hot beds of tension risks of global
conflict conflict have heightened in
order to curb them in order to bring
things on a peaceful path the Russian
Federation has and continues to insist
on all provisions of the United Nations
Charter being respected and applied not
selectively but fully in their full and
interconnected way this includes the
principle of The Sovereign equality of
states non-intervention in their
domestic affairs respect for territorial
sovereignty uh and teral integrity and
the right of people's to
self-determination and the actions of
the US and their allies attest to the
systematic violation of the balance of
needs which have been enshrined in the
charter since the collapse of the USSR
and establishment of independent states
in its place the US and its satellites
have egregiously and openly interfered
in the domestic affairs of Ukraine as
was publicly and even with pride
recognized by the deputy secretary uh
secretary deputy secretary of state
Victoria nuland in
2013 the 5 billion dollars were spent on
cultivating Ukrainian uh politicians in
Kev by the West all of the facts are
being swept under the rug their attempts
to cancel all of what happened since uh
prior to 2014 and for this reason the
theme of today's meeting proposed by the
Albanian presidency is most apt which
allows us to restore the chronological
succession of events specifically in the
context of relations of the main acting
parties in the implementation of the
principles and the purposes of the UN
Charter in 20044 to 2005 the West with
the aim of bringing to power
pro-american candidate sanction the
first coup in Kiev forcing the
Constitutional Court of Ukraine to adopt
an unlawful decision on the conduct of
something which was UN stated in the
Constitution namely a third round of
Elections and even more UNC un
ceremonial intervention domestic affairs
was cleared during the second midon in
2013 to 24 then a Litany of Western
leaders directly encouraged
participants directly part encourage
participants in anti-government
demonstrations and acts of violence the
same Victorian Anand discussed with the
US ambassador in Kiev the composition of
the future government to be comprised
composed of poist and the eu's real
place in World policy we all remember
her obscene two words showing that the
EU swallowed this in February 2014 the
US elected individuals who became key
participants in the brutal coup which
was organized I would recall one day
after what was reached under the
guarantees of Germany Poland and France
I refer to the agreement between the
legitimately elected president of
Ukraine and the opposition leaders the
principle of non-intervention in
domestic affairs was repeatedly trampled
upon immediately after the coup the
poist announced that their top priority
was to to deny the rights of Russian
language speakers in Ukraine and the
residents of Crimean southeast of the
country who refused to reconcile
themselves to the outcomes of the coup
were labeled terrorists a punitive
operation was Unleashed against them in
response to this Crimea and dbas
conducted referenda fully in line with
the principles of equality and
self-determination of peoples which are
enshrined in paragraph two of Article 1
of the UN Charter Western diplomats and
politicians visa Ukraine have been
turning a blind eye to this important
Norm of international law they have been
trying to take all the background and
the essence of what has happened and
trying to distill this to the
inadmissibility of violation of
territorial Integrity let us recall in
this connection a un Declaration was
adopted unanimously in 1970 uh this is a
declaration on the principle of
international law pertaining to Friendly
relations and cooperation amongst States
in line with the chart of the United
Nations enshrines the following the
principle for the respect of territorial
Integrity is applicable I quote to
States who in their actions comply with
the principle of equality and
self-determination of peoples and
subsequently having governments which
represent the ENT entire people residing
on the given territory and of quote to
the fact that the Ukrainian neo-nazis
who seized power in Kiev did not
represent the population of Crimea and
donbas is something which does not need
to be proven and the unconditional
support from Western capitals of the
actions criminal actions of the Kiev
regime is nothing other than a violation
of the principle of self-determination
subsequent to an egregious violation in
interference in domestic affairs pareno
and zilinski adopted racist laws on the
prohibition of everything Russian
education media culture the destruction
of books and monuments a Prohibition on
the Ukrainian Orthodox Church seizure of
its property these all became blatant
violations of paragraph 3 article one of
the UN Charter on the respect for human
rights and basic freedoms for all
without distinction as to race gender
language and religion
not to mention the fact that these
actions directly ran counter to the
constitution of Ukraine itself the
Constitution which sets out the
obligation of the state to respect the
rights of Russian and other National
minorities when we hear calls for
implementation of the peace formula to
bring Ukraine back to the
1991 uh Borders or question arises who's
being called for this those calling for
this are they familiar with the
statements of Ukrainian leadership about
what they intend to do with the
residents of the relevant territories
and with respect to them publicly at the
official level repeatedly there have
been threats voiced of of their physical
or legal Annihilation incidentally
similarly Western not only has not been
deterring its Western protes in Kev but
has enthusiastically been uh encouraging
this anti-russian policy incidentally
similarly members of the EU and NATO
have for decades been encouraging the
actions of laia and Estonia to strip the
rights of hundreds of thousands of
Russian language uh residents who have
been called non-citizens now there is a
serious discussion for the introduction
of criminal responsibility criminal
liability for the use of their mother
tongue senior officials officially state
that the spread of information about the
possibility of remote school programs
that this possibility needs to be
considered as something almost a threat
to to National Security which requires
the attention of law enforcement bodies
turning back to Ukraine in February 2015
the Minsk agreements were reached and
this included uh this the they were
approved by a special Security Council
resolution fully in line with article 36
of the charter which supports I quote
any procedure for the dis the resolution
of disputes that was adopted by the
parties in this specific case k of Danes
and lugansk however last year all of the
signatories of the k Minsk agreements
except for Mr uh Putin I refer to merel
aland and poroshenko publicly and with
some kind of pleasure even recognized
that having signed this document they
had no intention of implementing it they
were simply looking to gain time to
shore up the military capability of
Ukraine and to funnel weapons into the
country to be used against Russia for
all of these years if EU and NATO
directly supported the sabotage of the
Minsk agreements encouraged the KE
regime to use Force to address problems
in dbas and this was all in breach of
article 25 of the charter According to
which all members of the United Nations
agreed to accept and carry out the
decisions of the security Council let us
recall that the package of the Minsk
agreements the heads of Russia Germany
France and Ukraine signed a
declaration where Berlin and Paris
assumed an obligation to do a lot
including to help to restore the banking
system in dbas but they didn't move a
finger they merely observed how contrary
to all of those obligations penko
announced the trade economic and
transport blockade against dbas in that
same declaration Berlin and Paris Paris
assumed an obligation to comply with a
trilateral agreement in the EU Russia
Ukraine format to practically resolve
issues of concern to Russia in the area
of trade as well as to advance the
establishment of a shared humanitarian
economic space from Atlantic to the
Pacific I quote this declaration was
also endorsed by the security Council
and was also subject to implementation
in line with article 25 but this
obligation also of the leaders of
Germany and France was an empty promise
and yet another violation of chart of
principles recently the foreign minister
of the gro the Soviet Union uh prime
minister said better to have 10 years of
negotiations rather than a day of War
following this from we have been engaged
in painstaking negotiations reaching
agreements on European security we
approved the founding Russia NATO act we
adopted at the highest level the occe
Declaration on the indivisibility of
security in 1999 and in 2010 and
beginning with 2015 we insisted on the
unconditional implementation of the
Minsk agreements which emerged as a
result of negotiations and this was all
fully in line with the charter of the
United Nations which demands I quote to
ensure conditions for for the just and
respect for obligations which emanate
from treaties and other sources of
international law I quote and of course
and Western colleagues trampled upon
this PR this this Principle as well when
they signed on to these documents
knowing in advance that they had no
intention would not comply with this
this has been repeatedly seen and Mr
Putin referred to this repeatedly
including recently and I'd like to
remind the distinguished secretary of
state that president zilany
signed a decree prohibiting the conduct
of negotiations with the government of
Putin if the US is so interested in them
I don't think it would be very difficult
to give the command for the decree of
zelanski to be lifted now in our Western
opponents roric we hear slogans Invasion
aggression annexation not a word about
the root causes of the problems where
they cultivated and encouraged openly
Nazi regimes which openly rewrote the
outcomes of the second World War and the
history of their own people a
substantive negotiation based on facts
and respect for all of the requirements
of the UN Charter something which the
West has has avoided and it seem there
that that there is a fear of
professional discussions that would
reveal
demagoguery with incantations of
territorial Integrity former Colonial
Powers uh fail to mention the uh the
need for Paris to return the so-called
French in and the composition of the uh
vience for London to withdraw from The
Cho sailo to begin discussions with
buenos AOS on the mvenus islands these
supporters of territorial champions of
territorial Integrity in Ukraine now
make it appear as if they don't even
remember this the sense of the Minsk
agreements which lies I recall in the
reunification of dbas and Ukraine with
guarantee for respect for the
fundamental human rights first and
foremost the right to man's mother
tongue having torn part of these
agreements the West now Bears full
responsibility for the collapse of
Ukraine and for the fermenting of Civil
War there other principles in the
charter respect for which could have
prevented the security crisis in Europe
and could help to reach a an agreement
on the basis of balance of Interest I
would mention article two of article
8 which sets out the need to develop the
practice of peaceful resolution of
dispute with the assistance of regional
organizations in line with this
principle the Russian Federation
together with our allies has been
consistently advocating the restoration
of contacts between the collective
security Treaty Organization the CST and
NATO to facilitate the Practical
implementation of the above mentioned
outcomes of the occe summit on the
indivisibility of security which
stipulate among other things I quote not
a single state group of states or
organization can be vested with primary
responsibility for the maintenance of
peace and security and stability in the
OS CE region or consider any part of
that region as a sphere of influence of
its influence it's clear to all that
this is specifically what NATO was doing
in its attempt to create a
full uh superiority and in Europe and
now in the Asia Pacific however the
repeated appeals of uh bodies of the CS2
NATO were disregarded the reason for
such an arrogant position of the US and
their allies as we see once again today
lies in an unwillingness to engage in
any Equitable dialogue with any party if
NATO had not rejected the proposal of
the Cs to cooperate then perhaps we
could have avoided numerous negative
processes which resulted in the current
European crisis because uh Russia had
been not listened to or deceived for
decades today at the proposal of the
presidency we are discussing effective
multilateralism let us not forget the
numerous
facts of the genetic avoidance of the
west of any forms of Equitable
cooperation consider Joseph Bell's Pearl
that Europe is a flourishing Garden
surrounded by jungles this is purely NE
neocolonialism with disregard for
Sovereign equality of states and the
need to and disregard for strengthening
principles of the UN through effective
multilateralism trying to prevent
democratization in international
relations the US and its allies are
openly and unceremoniously trying to
privatize the Secretariat of of the UN
and circumvention of the secretar trying
to advance uncons mandates with claims
to have the right to accuse those who
for one reason or another are
inconvenient to Washington in this
connection let us recall the need for
stringent compliance with the charter
not just by member states but also by
the Secretariat of our organization
according to article 100 the Secretariat
has an obligation to act impartially and
should not receive any instructions from
any government we have already talked
about Article
2 and I wish to draw attention to a key
parent paragraph one an organization
based on the principles of sovereign
equality of states building upon this
principle the general assembly in the
above mentioned 1970 declaration
reaffirmed I quote the inalienable right
of each state to select for itself the
political economic social and cultural
system without intervention from any
side end of quote and in this connection
we have serious questions that arise
about the statements which our
distinguished Secretary General
delivered on the 29th of March that and
I quote of autocratic uh uh rule does
not guarantee stability this is a
catalyst for chaos and conflict and
robust Democratic societies are capable
of correcting themselves improving
themselves they can
stimulate change even radical change
without any blood letting or violence
one cannot but recall the changes that
were introduced by the aggressive
Misadventures of robust democracies in
Yugoslavia Afghanistan Iraq Libya Syria
and many others the distinguished
Secretary General then said they
democracies are the centers of broad
cooperation rooted in the principles of
equality participation and solidarity
end of quote worthy of note is that this
was all stated this is all announced by
something Biden uh convened beyond the
frame outside of the framework of the UN
the so-called Summit for democracy the
US Administration selected the
participants of this on the principle of
loyalty loyalty not so much for
Washington but rather the Democratic
party which uh rules in Washington
attempts to use a new formula uh to
address uh issues directly contradict
paragraph 4 article one of the UN
Charter which sets out the need I quote
to ensure the role of the organization
as a center for agreeing on action for
the achievement of shared goals contrary
to this principle many years ago France
Germany they proclaimed an alliance of
multilateralist where they also invited
only those who were obedient and this in
and of itself once again points to the
unshakable nature of the colonialist
mentality and the view of the initiators
of this meeting Visa the prin principle
of effective multilateralism in parallel
there was a narrative that was imposed
about the European Union as the ideal of
multilateralism now there are calls from
Brussels to expand the membership of the
EU as soon as possible to include
specifically the Balan countries but
most importantly it's not about Serbia
not about turkey where for decades
hopeless talks have been carried out for
their entry but rather this is about
Ukraine claim uh Joseph Burell recently
said that the of regime needs to be uh
accepted into the EU as soon as possible
apparently had it not been for the war
this would have taken years and now
there's a need to do so without respect
for any criteria Serbia turkey and
others they'll wait but the
Nazis uh will can skip the queue to
enter the ranks of the EU incidentally
at the same Democrat Summit for
democracy the Secretary General Proclaim
that democracy emanates from the charter
of the United Nations the first words of
the charter We the People reflects a
fundamental source of legitimacy the
consent of the governed quote it is
useful to compare this uh this this this
premise with the track record of the K
regime who beginning with the coup in
2014 and the war being Unleashed against
its own people against the millions of
people who did not consent to rule by
neo-nazis in rhobes thereby undermining
the territorial Integrity of Ukraine
those who contrary to the charter
divides Humanity in democracies and
autocracies failed to respond to the
question of what category they place the
Ukrainian regime in I won't answer for
wait for an answer so there's a question
about the uh the relationship between
the secretary the security Council and
the general assembly the Western
aggressive click has been pedling the
theme of abuse of the right of veto and
not with an incorrect focus on members
of of the UN they have uh
reached the result this was resulted in
the situation that after every exercise
of the reto veto the general assembly
considers the matter this is not a
problem for us at all because the
Russian approaches to all issues on the
agenda are open there is no it is does
not pose a difficulty for us to expound
on our positions or lay them out yet
again and the right to a veto is an
absolutely legitimate instrument which
is stipulated in the chart of the United
Nations to prevent
the adoption of decisions that would
divide the organization but if the
procedure for discussion of the general
assembly of applications of the veto is
was approved since this was approved
then why not consider why certain
resolutions without Anu Vito were that
were adopted including those many years
ago but are not being implemented
despite the provisions of article 25 of
the charter why would the general
assembly not considered the reasons
behind this this includes resolutions of
the security Council pal Palestine and
the whole range of issues related to the
Middle East the jcpoa resolution
222 which was approved which approved
the Minsk agreements on Ukraine also
worthy of attention is the problem
linked to sanctions regime regimes this
is now a Norm the security Council after
protracted negotiations fully in line
with the charter adopt sanctions against
a specific
country
is the problem linked to sanctions
regime regimes this is now a Norm the
security Council after protracted
negotiations fully in line with the
charter adopt sanctions against a
specific country subsequently the US and
its allies impose against that same
state additional supplemental unilateral
restrictions which did not secure the
consent of the security Council and are
not included in its resolution as part
of the agreed upon package this
includes another very egregious example
bar uh Berlin Paris and London just
adopted a decision through their
National legislative bodies for example
to extend something uh restrictions
against Iran that had were set to expire
in October uh which are subject to Legal
conclusion in line with resolution
2231 so the security Council uh has
determined that they have expired but
those countries decide that they decide
on the rules after this any adoption of
a account of a council of of
sanctions uh uh there there is a need to
consider the question of the adoption of
any sanctions by Security Council not be
overridden by the desires of others also
important is for sanctions regime
through the security Council to be time
Bound in so far as they're being
Unlimited in nature deprives the council
flexibility
Visa uh the impact on the sanction
government's policy there is a need to
consider humanitarian limitations of
sanctions for sanctions projects
introduced at the secured Council should
be accompanied by assessments about
their consequences through uh
consequences by humanitarian agencies of
the UN rather than being accompanied by
demagogic exhortations of Western
colleagues that simple that ordinary
people will not suffer the we see an
agree uh we see a deep crisis in
international relations and the lack of
willingness to redress this situation by
the west and the the organization is
responsible for the fate of uh the world
in the historic context there's a need
to abandon perial shortsighted
arrangements and national elections of
Any Given member State being taken to
account let us once again recall nearly
80 years ago having signed on to the UN
Charter world's leaders agreed to
respect the Sovereign equality of all
states large states small states poor
ones rich ones monarchies republics in
other words even then humankind
recognize the need for Equitable
polycentric world order as a guarantee
for the sustainability and security of
its development for this reason we're
not talking today about subordinating
ourselves to some kind of a rules-based
order but we are talking about
compliance with all of the obligations
which we shouldered when signing the
Charter in all of their integral and
inte and and and interconnected nature
thank
you
I thank his
Excellency Mr Sergey lvov and now I give
the floor To Her
Excellency Mrs
Katherine Colona Minister of
Foreign Affairs and Europe for the
Republic of France
microphone
please I thank the Secretary General for
his remarks I wish to take this
opportunity to begin by applauding the
statement delivered by the president of
Ukraine Vladimir Vadim zansi for the
past 18 months he has been embodied uh
Ukrainian action he has been the
countenance and the voice of millions of
Ukrainian people who have been fighting
for their freedom with admirable courage
before this Council whose mandate
focuses on International Peace and
security his call is something which we
need to respond to on 24 April 24
February 2022 the Russian Federation
chose to unleash a war of aggression
against the sovereign state in violation
of all its International commitments and
principles which for eight
decades
uh have prevailed in relations among
nations a war with no other motivation
than the Russian desire to restore its
dream of an imperial past despite the
fact that this had been condemned by
history this in Ukraine is evidently the
main victim of this war Ukraine and its
people every day endure atrocities War
war crimes shelling torture Ukrainian
children thousands of Ukrainian children
have been forcefully abducted from their
families and transferred to the Russian
Federation this is an
Abomination Ukrainian women men children
have endured Mass rape which has been
used as a war crime another
crime yes this war is a war against ukra
Ukraine against the Ukrainian people but
this is also a war against the rules of
international life for this is a war
against the most basic principles of our
shared Charter first and foremost the
respect for the sovereignty and
territorial Integrity of States this is
a war against the very idea of the
United Nations this is a war against the
pillars of our collective security at a
time when Russia has been
harnessing the security of nuclear
facilities as a leverage for the
advancement of its aggression this is a
war against shared Heritage of
humankind against cultural heritage
which Russia has been targeting in
adessa and elsewhere targeting Global
Food security with the sudden and
cynical termination of the black SE
grain initi I ative and more than
270,000 tons of grains have been
systematically destroyed by Russian
bombardment for a member of this Council
to use hunger as a weapon is yet another
transgression following on a Litany of
others and we need to consider the moral
implications of this this is a war which
concerns all of us for this reason we
will not not waiver in the face of this
aggression and the destabilization that
it has generated throughout the world
only a handful of states which states
one should consider support the
catastrophic choice of Russia the
general assembly like the security
Council are largely United around shared
principles how is it possible to pos
position backto back the aggressor and
the aggressed this approach delivers
neither peace nor Justice nor stability
if we allow the Russian aggression to be
rewarded today let us not deceive
ourselves we will once again have to uh
bring together the security Council in
this hall for there will be other
aggressions that will proliferate here
and elsewhere and nobody will be safe
any longer Mr President almost all
countries present here at this table
have in their more or less recent
history endured the trauma of War War
they experienced this
firsthand the destruction the human
tragedy which it carries in its wake and
they know that it is never a solution
tomorrow as is the case with every 21st
of September we commemorate the world
day of peace and we have a
responsibility and a moral duty to act
to end this aggression by Russia the
general assembly as in the AU expressly
call for on 21 September as has been the
case every day since the outbreak of
this war France has been mobilized and
will continue to mobilize to thwart this
aggression for our common good France
will continue to act on the basis of
shared principles the principle of
legitimate defense recognized by our
Charter we will continue to pursue
military and civil
support and civilian support to provide
Ukraine with what is necessary for it to
resist the aggression the principle of
justice and dignity we will continue to
support Ukrainian and international
jurisdictions to ensure that there is no
impunity for crimes perpetrated by
Russia the principle of solidarity we
will continue to pursue and to step up
our tangible support for the Count's
most hard hit by the global food crisis
provoked by Russia and we will step up
our humanitarian assistance to benefit
people in need throughout the world Mr
President the Primacy of law over Force
International solidarity and support for
the most vulnerable are principles which
lie at the heart of President zelensky's
peace formula this is why each day more
and more of us support
it I call upon all states who have not
yet done so to work to that end thank
you
I thank Her
Excellency Dam Kona for her statements
and I now give the floor to his
Excellency Mr MAA Minister for foreign
affairs of the federative Republic of
[Music]
Brazil I thank the presidency of the
security Council for organizing this
meeting Mr President the conflict in
Ukraine has added numerous stresses to
the multilateral system which was
already subject to multiple complex
challenges and increasing descent the
current context of polarization and
distrust does not create favorable
conditions for the multilateral
instances of International Peace and
security to operate effectively the
world is facing the highest number of
violent conflicts since World War II and
two billion people a quarter of humanity
are living in areas affected by
conflicts yet our Collective inst
institutions are not adequately
responding to these challenges as the
concept note of this debate rightly put
points out the inability of the security
Council to adequately fulfill its
mandate is undering its credibility and
leading to renewed calls for its long
overdue
reform in these trouble times a daunting
VI of daunting violations of core values
of the principles of the United Nations
Brazil has been encouraging member
states to revive the spirit of San
Francisco in the search for peace for
present and future Generations which is
the fundamental mission of this
organization Brazil fully respects and
upholds the right of self-defense of all
member states under article 51 of un
Charter at the same time we must
recognize that the recent escalation in
the conflict with introduction of even
more sophisticated weapons and
ammunition or the inadmissible threat of
use of nuclear weapons seriously
undermines peace and security well
beyond the battlefield violating the
core principles and provisions of the UN
Charter this Dynamic has Grave consequen
quences above all for the civilian
population in particular women and
children who are disproportionately
affected by Wars the destruction of
Civilian
infrastructure worsens the humanitarian
crisis especially as winter approaches
moreover the persistent threat to the
Integrity of nuclear facilities
risks a catastroph of in inimaginable
able proportions Mr President as we are
as we have consistently noted the war in
Ukraine also affects other regions
especially as developing countries bear
the burden of food and energy
insecurity we welcome the secretary
General's effort to explore alternatives
to alleviate the suffering of millions
of people who once again face hunger or
the threat of hunger Brazil strongly
supports a resumption of the Black Sea
grain initiative under terms that would
be acceptable to all concerned parties
Brazil also underscores the need for
addressing the root causes of food and
energy insecurity such as excessively
High interest rates and external debt
that severely impact prices and the
ability of developing countries to
invest in sustainable food and energy
prod production the current
International Financial structure is not
well equipped to assist these countries
address their major
challenges as recently announced by
President Lula Brazil will launch during
our G20 presidency a global alliance
against hunger this is a top priority
for Brazil and should be for all of us
Mr President
it's worrisome that we are witnessing a
conflict with such geopolitical
reverberations well into the 21st
century we must Reserve this course we
must reverse this course Brazil along
with many others continue to call for
the deescalation of hostilities the
resumption of dialogue and a peaceful
solution to the conflict this is an
obligation of all member states under
article 33 of the UN
Charter there is no military solution to
this conflict only a political solution
that takes into account the purpose and
principles of the UN Charter and the
legitimate security concerns of all
parties will bring lasting peace the
International Community will have to
assist the parties to come to a
negotiated and Lasting solution Brazil
is prepared to do its part Mr President
president the space for diplomacy and
peaceful solution is
narrowing we must set aside practices
that only deepen Visions instead of
contributing to a more peaceful world
and work together renewed
multilateralism Brazil firmly advocates
for mediation and preventive diplomacy
as indispensable tools to prevent the
escalation of crisis with this view
Brazil has been engaged in several fora
to deal with the Ukrainian crisis we
have sent High representatives to
Copenhagen and jeda we have also spoken
bilaterally to the concerned parties we
strongly encourage that in these
conversations both parties should be
heard and their views carefully taken
into
consideration talking to only one part
or the other will not help advancing the
cause of durable peace a compreh
comprehensive approach as
suggested will be the only way forward
to enable peaceful
negotiations with that in mind we will
organize next month during our
presidency of the security Council a
high level open debate on the
contributions of regional sub Regional
and bilateral arrangements to the
prevention and peaceful resolution of
this of this
I count on your participation in October
thank you Mr
President I thank is Excellency Mr via
for his statement and now I give the
floor To Her Excellency Mrs Mariam almi
minister of climate change and
environment chief of the international
Affairs office at the Presidential Court
of the United Arab Emirates thank you Mr
President I extend my gratitude to
Secretary General gutterz for his
valuable briefing and wish to
acknowledge the heads of state and
government and other highlevel
Representatives present today I also
welcome the participation of President
selinski I commend Albania for convening
this critical open debate the UAE has
long advocated for a peaceful resolution
to the war in Ukraine that upholds the
UN
Charter the war has wrought a
devastating toll on human life in
including the displacement of almost two
out of every three children in Ukraine
the country now Bears the Grim record
for the highest concentration of
landmines in the world rendering nearly
onethird of the country no longer safe
uh due to unexploded ordinance this
conflict has further ra ravaged food and
transport
infrastructure we stress once again the
need for all parties to comply with
their obligations under international
human humanitarian law and specifically
the protection of those objects
indispensable to the survival of the
civilian
population we are deeply concerned by
the ramifications of the destruction of
infrastructure on Survivor Services
health care and other critical forms of
support especially on women and children
who already bear the brunt of armed
conflict the UAE has pledged $ 100
million us to help address the
humanitarian crisis
we have sent 11 airlifts of relief and
medical supplies for children and the
elderly provided more than 2,500
generators and sent 23 ambulances just
this week the UA has also provided $4
million
Us in funding for first lady oena telena
foundation's programming for
Orphans Beyond Ukraine the war's Global
Ripple effects are evident especially in
the pronounced impact on food security
including in our own region let me
restate that the UAE remains steadfast
in supporting the renewal of the Black
Sea grain initiative and the full
implementation of theou on Russian
fertilizers and food products as well as
any discussions that support these goals
Mr President while crucial these
measures only alleviate rather than end
suffering world leaders especially this
week in the general assembly have made
clear the global desire for a just and
sustainable peace in Ukraine one that
upholds the UN Charter a diverse set of
countries is increasingly coming
together around the common cause of
Peace in Ukraine we welcome the role
played by countries such as the Kingdom
of Saudi Arabia and China as well as the
African Peace initiative and supporting
all possible routs to a peaceful
settlement in these calls there is
growing recognition of the urgency of
the task not just for Ukraine but for
all of us
the war Amplified the erosion of faith
in multilateralism achieving peace can
begin its
restoration of course Peace will only
come out of diplomatic talks between
Russia and Ukraine and it will only be
just and sustainable if it upholds the
UN Charter the UN Security Council and
its members have a vital role to play in
this process we can encourage and
incentivize deescalation extend thec see
to uphold the UN Charter to every file
before us and expand the circle of
peacemakers to reflect today's Global
realities we would welcome an
increasingly representative council and
believe the discussions on Security
Council reform should move forward with
serious intention though the path to
peace in Ukraine may be arduous it
doesn't license in action there is only
one sustainable path to a just and
Lasting peace in Ukraine in line with
the UN Charter and preserving its
sovereignity independence and
territorial integrity and the UAE stands
ready to support that objective thank
you Mr
President I thank Her Excellency is
Almighty for a statement and I give the
floor to his Excellency Mr MAA Su
Executive Vice Minister of Foreign
Affairs of the People's Republic of
China
thank you Mr President Mr
President China's position on the
Ukraine issue is consistent and
clear president Xi Jinping put forward
four points on what must be done four
things the International Community must
do together and three
observations they have become
fundamental guidance for China to handle
the Ukraine issue we believe that the
sovereignty and the territory Integrity
of all countries should be
respected the purposes and the principle
of the UN Charter
observed the legitimate security
concerns of all countries taken
seriously and all efforts conducive to
resolving the
crisis
supported in February this year we
released China's position on the
political settlement of the Ukraine
crisis laying out 12 propositions
including respecting sovereignty ceasing
hostilities resuming talks stopping
unilateral sanctions Etc the core
message is facilitating talks for
peace China has maintained close
communication on the Ukraine crisis with
various relevant parties and rest of the
International Community the special
representative of the Chinese government
on uration Affairs has visited countries
concerned and attended the International
Conference on Ukraine in
jeda China has facilitated talks for
peace in its own way and played a
positive and constructive role in
resolving the Ukraine
crisis Mr
President the Ukraine crisis is still on
the intense situation on the
Battleground and accumulating risks of
spear over have exerted a significant
impact
internationally the Ukraine crisis has
become what it is today for a variety of
deep and complex
reasons a prolonged and expanded Ukraine
crisis is in no one's
interest in light of the current
situation I would like to stress on the
following Four Points first stay
committed to to facilitating talks for
peace history has proven that conflict
produces no winner and War cannot solve
problems the pursuit of one's absolute
security all efforts to stoke block
confrontation will only intensify
disagreement and conflict and will come
to no good however complicated the
situation or challenging the task it is
important to stick to the general
direction of political settlement help
parties concerns to be build consensus
initiate talks for peace and cease
hostilities at an early date to this end
the International Community need to
create necessary conditions at
atmosphere relevant parties need to take
a Long View uphold the vision of common
comprehensive cooperative and
sustainable security respect each
other's legitimate security concerns and
promote the building of a balanced
effective and sustainable security
architecture in
Europe second
avoid pouring oil over the fire all
parties should exercise restraint and
not increase or asate tension refrain
from taking any initiatives that lead to
a steady escalation of the
situation and work to create necessary
conditions for political settlement we
should Safeguard the bottom line of
nuclear security and prevent man-made
nuclear a accident third manage the
spillover risks
the Ukraine crisis has dealt a heavy
blow toward World economic recovery and
Global
development and severely affected the
world food energy and Financial Security
developing countries are the first to
Bear the blun brunt relevant countries
should stop abusing unilateral sanctions
and longarm jurisdiction and protect the
security and smooth operation of Global
Production and Supply chains we support
relevant parties in maintaining
communication with Russia and ukra
Ukraine on the Block on the Black Sea
Green deal and assuming the deal on the
basis of balanced consideration of the
concerns of both sides with a view to
earnestly protecting Global Food
security fourth e the humanitarian
crisis in
2023 as many as 339 million people
around the world are in need of
humanitarian Aid some 70 million more
than at the beginning of
2022 the Ukraine crisis has produced
millions of based people and destroyed
multiple important large scale
infrastructure the parties to the
conflict should strictly observe
International humanitarian law follow
the principles of necessity distinction
and proportionality protect civilians
and civilian
infrastructure and provide Rapid Safe
and unimpeded humanitarian access in
order to lessen the suffering of
civilians the International Community
and the humanitarian institutions should
honor the principles of humanitarian Aid
and step up efforts to help people
affected tied over
difficulties China attaches great
importance to the humanitarian situation
in Ukraine we at the beginning of the
crisis we put
forward a six-point Initiative for
preventing a massive humanitarian crisis
and have all along played a constructive
role in easing in easing the
humanitarian situation we have provided
multiple batches of humanitarian
supplies
to Ukraine Mr President China will stay
committed well stay committed to the
true multilateralism stay committed to
an objective and just position and will
always stand on the side of dialogue on
the side of peace and on the side of
right on the right side of
History we are ready to work with
Security Council Members and relevant
parties to continue playing a
constructive role for the political
settlement of the Ukraine crisis thank
you Mr
President thank you your Excellency Mr
ma for your statement and now I give the
floor to representatives of
mozambik thank you very much Mr
President I wish to thank the Albanian
presidency for convening this uh
briefing we also wish to express our
deep gratitude to the Secretary General
for his valuable insights Mr President
it is not redundant that we remind
ourselves of the importance of
multilateralism forer in
cooperation partnership interaction
between states based on a shared system
of norms and
values
multilateralism also involves
consultation dialogue inclusion respect
solidarity and is Guided by collectively
developed rules that ensure sustainable
and effective
cooperation more significantly the
importance of multilateralism lies in
its ability to enable as sovereign
states to solve complex challenges
collectively that they could be
not overcome
individually by naturing peace before
during and after conflicts
multilateralism contributes to
sustainable and Lasting
peace it is in this regard that the
security Council must play its crucial
role in maintaining International Peace
and security by facilitating political
process protecting civilians preventing
Wars promoting human rights and
restoring the rule of law Mr President
this protracted conflict between Russia
and Ukraine constitutes a great risk to
the maintenance of Global Peace and
security this in essence perfectly
illustrate the struggle metalism
faces despite numerous International
appeals including from this very Council
we are now entering the
574th day of
hostilities with Moun civilian
casualties and no clear end in
sight it is indeed a 21st century
tragedy unfolding under our Collective
gaze and the scrutiny of the entire
world this conflict unfolds both on the
battlefield and amidst a perlex and
divided public opinion pushing our
contemporary multilateral system to its
Breaking
Point our malal system as we all can
attest has despite its imperfections
weathered numerous
crisis this ongoing crisis POS a serious
threat to this foundational principle of
global
stability not only has the conflict
caused immense suffering for Ukraine and
its people but it has also compounded
Global Food security issues pushing more
individuals into poverty and
destabilizing regions far from the
epicenter
moreover this conflict impedes our joint
efforts to reach vital multilateral
Milestones like the sustainable de
development goals which are a focal
topic of this year's general assembly
and jeopardizes our Collective effort
toward non
proliferation Mr President of particular
in concern to mosm is the the
intensification of military rhetoric and
the possibility of further
escalation it is evident that involved
parties continue to prioritize military
strategies over dialogue and compromise
increasing the risk of severe
miscalculations we maintain that there
can there can be no purely military
resolution to this crisis should one be
pursued it will weigh heavily on the
council's conscience for Generation to
come we remain un yielding in our
advocacy for a political and
negotiated end to this
conflict we once again urge all parties
to silence the ghis engage in Earnest in
diplomatic efforts aimed at the Swift
resumption of direct
negotiations a lasting peace consistent
with the chter remains the sole valuable
solution I thank you Mr
President I thank the distinguished
representative of mozambik and now I
give the floor to his
Excellency uh the chancellor of Germany
Mr
Schultz Mr President colleagues
excellencies it has been almost 19
months since Russia started a brutal war
of aggression against its Sovereign
neighbor
Ukraine tens of thousands of soldiers
and Ukrainian civilians have been killed
countless Ukrainian children have been
abducted Russian troops have murdered
raped and tortured they are raising
towns and villages to the ground they
are mining entire regions turning
cornfields into death
traps this war is taking place in Europe
but its repercussions are felt
throughout the world
Russia has deliberately removed millions
of tons of grains and fertilizer from
the World Market which countries around
the globe need to guarantee food
security Russia is deliberately
targeting grain CEOs and port
infrastructures and Russia has withdrawn
unilaterally from the Black Sea grain
initiative triggering more poverty and
more food insecurity all over the world
there is no justification for that any
claims that sanctions are hampering
Russian exports of crops and fertilizer
are false there are no sanctions
impeding such exports on the contrary
Russia dominates the global fertilizer
Market 2022 was a record year for
Russian wheat
exports the reason for the continued
suffering in Ukraine and around the
world is shockingly simple
Russia's president wants to follow
through with his imperialistic plan to
conquer his Sovereign neighbor
Ukraine Mr President the United Nations
has expressed expressed very clearly
what it thinks of Russia's war of
aggression most recently on the 23rd of
February of this year the general
assembly called of just and Lasting
peace this demand is directed at Russia
it remains
unanswered nothing rings out louder
today than Russia's silence and response
to this Global call for
peace some argue that this war could
have been prevented by diplomatic means
in fact France and Germany have held
hundreds of meetings with Moscow and
Kiev since the beginning of Russia's
attack on eastern Ukraine in
2014 our aim was to find a diplomatic
solution that is in line with
international
law all these Endeavors failed because
one party Russia choose War over
diplomacy but there has been no lack of
diplomatic efforts some call for
immediate ceased fire I acknowledge
their good intentions we all want an end
to the killing today rather than
tomorrow and yet we must beware of
seemingly easy solutions that promise
peace in name only peace without freedom
is oppression and peace without Justice
is a dictate in the resolutions of the
general assembly we have laid out the
path towards peace peace means
respecting the UN Carter peace means
respecting the territorial integrity and
political independence of Ukraine that
is the promise of un Cara gives to every
United Nations member State no one Longs
for peace more more than the
ukrainians the peace plan that the
Ukrainian president has laid out is
proof of that the recent meetings in
Copenhagen and jeda were important this
work work should be
continued it should be continued in the
pursuit of one goal finding peace that
respects the principles of the UN
Carter Mr President the more
decisively we rally Behind These
principles
the more determined we are in pushing
for a just peace and the more united we
are in our rejections of Russian
aggression the sooner this war will end
the sooner this human suffering will end
in Ukraine and around the world this
goal this goal is worth our utmost
efforts thank you I thank the chancellor
of federal republic of Germany his
Excellency Mr Olaf Schultz there are
still a considerable number of speakers
remaining on my list for this meeting so
I intend with concurrence of members of
the council to suspend the meeting until
15:30 or 3:30 p.m. for our American
friends so uh the meeting is
suspending